Sie ist eine Kanzlerin.
Das ist nicht verboten.
Ihr hört CRE Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ja, ich sag Hallo zu allen, die hier wieder zugeschaltet haben und die sich schon wieder gewundert haben, die den Titel gelesen haben, worum es denn jetzt wohl mal gehen könnte. Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft, ich glaub der Teil Technik kommt heute nicht ganz so zum Einsatz, aber über Kultur und Gesellschaft wollte ich auf jeden Fall mal sprechen und zwar über einen Raum, der ja gerade Deutschland im letzten Jahr nochmal mit einer ganz anderen Heftigkeit berührt hat, als das bisher schon der Fall war und was auch international natürlich immer wieder ein Thema ist, nämlich die arabische Welt. Konkreter werden wir hier wohl einen Blick werfen auf Länder wie Ägypten und vor allem auch auf Saudi-Arabien und das hat viel mit unserem Gast zu tun, nämlich mit Miriam. Miriam, Miriam Seifath, aber man kennt dich eigentlich unter Nojoom. Nojoom ist richtig.
Genau, ist richtig. Nojoom ist der Nickname, den ich im Internet benutze. Ich glaube, den habe ich mir ausgesucht, als ich mich bei Twitter angemeldet habe 2011. Und das ist ein arabischer Frauenvorname, der vor allem auf der arabischen Halbinsel verwendet wird. Und wie viele arabische Namen ist das ein sprechender Name, also sozusagen ein Wort, das eigentlich eine Bedeutung hat, was aber als Name verwendet wird. Und in dem Fall ist das der Plural von Stern und heißt Sterne.
Sterne?
Sterne, genau.
Was ist denn der Singular von Stern?
Najm. Najm ist der Singular und der Plural ist Nojoom.
Warum hast du nicht den Singular genommen?
Ich finde Nojoom irgendwie schöner. Ich glaube, ich saß irgendwann mal vor vielen Jahren in Kairo in einem kleinen Laden und hatte ein Buch mit arabischen Vornamen in der Hand und habe das einfach so durchgeblättert. Ich legte mich auf diesen Namen und fand ihn schön.
Okay, der ist auch ein Pluralgängig.
Genau, das ist als Pluralgängig als Frauenname.
Ich weiß gar nicht, gibt es da irgendein Äquivalent bei uns? Ist ja eh nicht so angemessen in unserer Namenswelt, uns an irgendwas, eine Natur zu orientieren.
Ich glaube, die meisten Namen, die die Leute hier bei uns haben, die haben ja auch alle häufig irgendeine Bedeutung, die dann aus dem Griechischen oder Lateinischen kommt oder so. Die ist uns nur halt nicht so klar, wenn man auf den ersten Blick auf den Namen guckt. Aber wenn du dann zum Beispiel in so einem Vornamenbuch nachschlagen würdest, würdest du die Bedeutung auch finden.
Ja, das ist dann meistens immer so religiöser, klimm, bim. Nujum, so kennt man dich.
Genau.
Was auch schon mal so ein bisschen andeutet, dass du so eine arabische Affinität am Start hast. Und wo kommt die her?
Ich werde das ganz häufig gefragt. Ich habe ja auch im Master Islamwissenschaften studiert und ganz häufig fragen mich die Leute, warum hast du das eigentlich studiert? Wie bist du da überhaupt drauf gekommen? Ich finde das irgendwie so ein bisschen genauso schwer zu erklären, wie wenn man jemanden fragt, warum interessierst du dich für Opern oder warum spielst du gerne Fußball? Das ist einfach so ein... Irgendwann ist das erweckt worden, sagen wir mal so. Rückblickend hat man immer das Gefühl, dass die Veranlagung schon immer da war oder das Interesse. Ich bin schon in relativ jungen Jahren das erste Mal in Israel gewesen und vielleicht da so der erste Kontakt mit dem Nahen und Mittleren Osten und das Interesse dafür. Und ich habe im Bachelor erstmal Geschichte und Philosophie studiert und dann irgendwann hat mir im ersten oder zweiten Semester eine Freundin erzählt, dass es so auch so verrückte Masterstudiengänge gibt, wo man sich mit dem Nahen und Mittleren Osten beschäftigen kann. Irgendwie habe ich in dem Moment sofort gedacht, so das wäre doch mal total cool.
Okay, also es war dann im Prinzip erst eine Spezialisierung, die dann einem Geschichtsstudium gefolgt ist.
Genau, ich habe auch ein Faible für Sprachen sowieso und wenn man so ein kulturwissenschaftliches Studium macht, dass ich mit einer bestimmten Region beschäftigt, also im weiteren Sinne Regionalwissenschaften hat man auch die Gelegenheit, viele weitere Sprachen zu lernen. In meinem Fall war das Arabisch und Türkisch, aber ein bisschen Hebräisch kann ich auch und das hat dann ganz gut gepasst. Man hat die Gelegenheit, viel zu reisen. Also fließend kann ich Deutsch, Englisch und Französisch. Französisch war meine erste Fremdsprache, aber Englisch kann ich auch fließend und Arabisch würde ich sagen, spreche ich mittelgut. Das habe ich schon, im Bachelor habe ich schon mein Arabikum gemacht. Türkisch hatte ich leider nur ein Jahr in der Uni dann und Hebräisch habe ich so bei meinen diversen Reisen so Learning by Doing mal gemacht. Ich habe auch das Latinum gemacht während meines Bachelor, aber ich finde das zählt nicht, weil das keine lebende Sprache ist und man die nicht üben kann und ich davon fast alles wieder vergessen habe, nachdem ich die Prüfung abgelegt habe.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich auch nur damit man danach so Asterix-Zitate mal eben schnell runterrasseln kann, ohne sich dafür zu schämen, dass man es nicht weiß, was es eigentlich bedeutet. Okay, aber das ist ja dann auch sagen wir mal jetzt nicht so normal, dass man jetzt so eine breite Sprachausrichtung allein schon im Westeuropäischen hat. Also ich meine, wenn du sagst fließend, also gut französisch habe ich mal gelernt, fließend, no.
Hat sich bei mir so ergeben, wie gesagt war meine erste Fremdsprache habe ich in der dritten Klasse schon irgendwie die erste Fremdsprachen AG gehabt und ab der fünften Klasse, wo die Leute üblicherweise Englisch als Hauptfach haben, hatte ich französisch als Hauptfach und Englisch dann erst ab der siebten. Und das macht, man sagt ja immer, bei dem Sprachenlernen macht das so viel aus, in welchem Alter man anfängt. Und das ist wirklich so, ich habe das Gefühl, alle Leute, die erst in der siebten mit französisch anfangen, mit der zweiten als zweite Fremdsprache, ich habe das Gefühl, die quälen sich da in den meisten Fällen so durch, aber dadurch, dass es meine erste Fremdsprache war, ist das irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, habe ich das so eingeatmet.
Ich habe also in der zweiten Klasse angefangen, aber es hat mein Verhältnis zu französisch auch nicht verbessert, aber ich schiebe das mal auf meine eigene Faulheit und so. Wobei man muss dann glaube ich auch irgendwie schon so ein Ding am Laufen haben, dass manchen Leuten fällt das halt einfach leicht, irgendwie Sprachen rein zu pfeifen, aber ich habe auch so ein bisschen die Vermutung, dass das einen eigentlich auch, ja, so zum globalen Menschen geschmiedet bekommt, wenn man einfach versteht, dass Dinge auch anders heißen können, auch andere Bedeutungen haben kann oder dass es eine Übersetzung nicht immer nur eine direkte Umschreibung einzelner Worte ist, sondern dass man einfach in anderen Kulturräumen auch einfach mal ganz andere Formulierungen finden muss. So würden wir das nicht sagen.
Es öffnet einem auch einfach Türen, also jetzt so global gesehen, wenn man sich Länder anguckt. Also ich fühle mich wesentlich relaxter in Länder zu reisen, wo ich das Gefühl habe, da komme ich mit meinen Sprachen klar. Ich war zum Beispiel, als ich 14 war oder so, habe ich so einen Roundtrip gemacht in Mittelamerika, in Salvador, Honduras und Guatemala, weil mein Partneronkel da lebt und ich habe nie Spanisch gelernt, aber durch das Französisch habe ich immer die Schlüsselwörter verstanden und wusste, worum es ging. Aber zum Beispiel, ich habe überhaupt keine Affinität zum asiatischen Raum, weil da meine Sprachkenntnisse irgendwie außer Englisch lost sind und ich habe jetzt überhaupt kein Problem bei der Vorstellung, in irgendein beliebiges arabisches Land zu reisen, in dem ich noch nicht war, weil ich da überhaupt keine Angst hätte, am Busbahnhof verloren zu gehen oder so. Ich habe es gut gedacht, ich würde mich immer zurechtfinden, ich wäre immer in der Lage, die Leute nach dem Weg zu fragen oder meine Bedürfnisse, Kunst zu tun oder mich auszutauschen, aber das ist zum Beispiel beim asiatischen Raum nicht der Fall. Dadurch habe ich das Gefühl, dass wie bei so einem Civilization oder so oder bei so einem Rollenspiel, dass die Karte, die sich für mich erkundet, die für mich erschlossen ist, durch Sprachen einfach, durch diese Sprachen auch definiert ist, in gewisser Hinsicht.
Das ist vielleicht ein ganz guter Einstieg. Immer die arabische Sprache, wir haben so viel, scheint es mir, nicht gemein, wenn man jetzt mal von den Ziffern absieht. Ist das schon mal ein richtiger Eindruck oder stimmt das eigentlich gar nicht so? Sie klingt fremd, sie liest sich natürlich noch viel fremder durch die anderen Schriftzeichen, durch das rechts nach links und alles.
Es gibt tatsächlich eine ganze Reihe Wörter, die wir im Deutschen verwenden, die aus dem Arabischen kommen, ohne dass wir es wissen. Jetzt fahren wir natürlich nicht so wahnsinnig viele Beispiele ein, außer irgendwie Kadi, was ein veraltetes Wort für Richter ist und tatsächlich, ich glaube die Wörter Kaffee und Alkohol kommen auch aus dem Arabischen und nicht aus dem Deutschen. Es gibt bestimmt auch mehr, die mir jetzt gerade nicht einfallen, aber es gibt Beispiele und ja, die zahlen natürlich auch.
Aber wie leicht ist es denn, also ich meine, vielleicht bist du ja jetzt so ein Sprachentausendzasser und hübser einfach rein, aber was muss man denn erstmal verstehen, was da ganz anders läuft in der arabischen Sprache als in unseren westlichen Sprachprägungen?
Ich würde sagen, die arabische Sprache ist schon ganz anders als die westlichen und romanischen Sprachen. Und andere Sprachen fallen mir auch wesentlich leichter, schneller zu lernen. Also wenn ich mich jetzt hinsetzen würde und sagen würde, ich würde jetzt mal ein bisschen Spanisch oder Italienisch lernen, glaube ich, fällt einem das viel leichter, wenn man schon andere romanische Sprachen kann, als jetzt bei arabisch. Ich finde selbst, ich finde, dass selbst türkisch und hebräisch sich im Verhältnis zu arabisch wie europäische Sprachen anfühlen, weil es mehr oder weniger die gleichen Laute sind, die man produziert und die Grammatik noch leichter nachzuvollziehen ist, so aus einer deutschen oder westlichen Perspektive. Im Arabischen hast du erstmal alle möglichen Buchstaben und Laute tatsächlich, die wir nicht haben, die kompliziert zu produzieren sind, die man erstmal lernen muss, auszusprechen. Die haben zum Beispiel viele verschiedene Haarlaute und die haben zum Beispiel das betonte Haar. Das klingt dann so Haa, wie ein Hub und Habibi. Also wenn wir das einfach, wenn man einfach so jetzt im Deutschen das Wort Habibi benutzt, also wissen ja die meisten, was das bedeutet, dann sagt man es einfach normal und sagt Habibi, aber eigentlich wird das mit einem betonten Haar ausgesprochen, mit einem Haar, das geht noch. Aber dann gibt es auch Würgelaute, die hinten im Hals produziert werden, zum Beispiel das Ein. Es gibt Knacklaute, die am Ende eines Wortes kommen, die wir üblicherweise am Anfang haben, also zum Beispiel in Auto oder Achtung ganz am Anfang bei dem Vokal, den man sagt, da ist so ein leichter Knacklaute. Man sagt ja nicht Haa, sondern Ah. So und im Arabischen hast du diese Knacklaute am Ende vom Wort und es ist unfassbar schwierig, das auszudrücken. Es gibt einen Platz in Cairo, der heißt Midan Gala und das ist halt ein langes A am Ende und am Ende von dem langen A kommt noch ein Knacklaut. Gala. Die Taktikärer haben immer nicht gewusst, wo ich hin will. Es hat lange gedauert.
Also es ist mehr so ein abruptes Ende als vielmehr ein eigener Sound, also mehr so ein definiertes Ende, kein Auslaufen des A's, sondern mehr so ein da ist auch Schluss.
Und dann gibt's noch Knacklaute im Wort und viele verschiedene, dann gibt es das betonte D, viele verschiedene D- und T-Laute, die wir nicht haben. Und gerade wenn die dann in einer komplizierten Kombination sind, wird das schon ganz schön schwer.
und T-Laute, die wir nicht haben.
Ja, also es gibt irgendwie vier verschiedene Ds und vier verschiedene Ts. So und die musst du erstmal, also ich kann die bis heute nicht perfekt unterschiedlich sprechen. Mir kommt zugute, dass die verschiedenen Dialekte in der arabischen Welt, die auch unterschiedlich aussprechen. Und im Zweifelsfalle denkt jemand, dass ich einen Dialekt spreche, den er noch nicht gehört hat. Also im Groben werden die Worte dann schon verstanden, aber das ist schon sehr kompliziert einfach, das auszusprechen. Und dann ist die Grammatik natürlich auch ganz anders. Die ist sehr logisch, wenn man sich da einmal reingedacht hat. Einfach ganz anders als bei uns. Auch die Wörter sind ganz anders strukturiert. Die Wörter haben immer so einen Stamm, der aus drei Buchstaben besteht, der sozusagen eine Bedeutungsgruppe umfasst. Also alles, was mit Büchern und Lesen zum Beispiel zu tun hat. Und alles, was irgendwie mit Büchern oder Lesen zu tun hat, ist auf drei Buchstaben diesen Wortstamm zurückzuführen. Und da werden dann drum herum verschiedene Wortarten gebildet. Und dann kannst du zum Beispiel an dem Wort, wenn du das Verb Lesen erkennst, kannst du, selbst wenn du das Wort Bibliothek noch nie gesehen hast, kannst du dir aus dem Aufbau des Wortes erschließen, aha, es ist zurück zu führen auf das Verb Lesen. Und das Wort bezeichnet einen Ort, an dem man geht, um Dinge zu tun. Also bedeutet es wahrscheinlich Bibliothek. Magtaba. Also das Verb Lesen heißt Kataba und wenn es ein Ort ist, an dem man geht, dann ist ein M am Anfang wie ein Magtaba und das heißt, man kann sich das ganz gut erschließen, aber es ist trotzdem.
Ist die Logik dann so durchgehend auch? Also ist es dann in sich sehr logisch?
In sich ist es sehr logisch.
Weil dann ist es ja eigentlich immer nicht so das Problem.
Ja gut, aber es gibt einfach trotzdem ganz schön viele verschiedene Regeln, die du lernen und können musst. Und ich finde auch konjugieren bis heute schwierig. Also ich würde gerne sehr, sehr viel besser Arabisch sprechen, als ich es tatsächlich tue. Im Zweifelsfall, ich sage immer, ich rede dann, wenn ich versuche, mich verständlich zu machen, ich rede dann so ein Sesamstraßen-Arabisch, wo weiß ich nicht, wenn mir die richtige Form nicht einfällt, dann benutze ich halt den Infinitiv und die Leute verstehen, was ich sagen will. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so das super geschliffene Arabisch, was ich spreche.
Also ich tendiere dann auch eher so zum Verstummen und so. Ich habe mal versucht, Spanisch zu lernen und habe eigentlich eine verhältnismäßig effektive, alle um mich herum aber vollkommen verstörende Methode entwickelt, die darin bestand, erstmal drei Wochen lang stumm am Strand zu sitzen und Grammatik zu lesen. Hab mir das dann eigentlich so nördmäßig so reingehämmert, dass ich dann also wirklich diese ganze Grammatik und Zeiten und alles, also ich hatte alles voll gespeichert. Das war einfach intensiv. Mein Tag bestand einfach nur aus Sonne, was man da so am Strand so gereicht bekommt und halt irgendwie dieses Buch. Und danach bin ich irgendwie eine Woche in eine Spanisch-Schule reingegangen und die hat mich irgendwie mit großen Augen angeschaut, woher ich denn das eigentlich wüsste. Obwohl ich doch eigentlich gar nicht so...
Was das Ganze noch komplizierter macht, was man aber wissen muss, ist, es gibt das Hocharabisch, was aber fast niemand spricht. Also das ist häufig das, was man jetzt zum Beispiel an der Universität lernen würde oder wenn du hier in Berlin, weiß ich nicht, zur Volkshochschule gehst oder so. Da lernst du Wörter und Grammatik, aber das spricht außer Straße niemand, weil in den verschiedenen arabischen Ländern die Leute ganz unterschiedliche Dialekte sprechen, die teilweise sehr, sehr stark von diesem Hocharabischen abweichen. Das heißt, wenn du in einem konkreten arabischen Land überleben möchtest, dann musst du deren Dialekt lernen. Das heißt, im Endeffekt sprichst du dann fast schon wieder mehrere Sprachen, weil du kennst vielleicht das Hocharabische, dass du, wie in meinem Fall, an der Uni gelernt hast zum Beispiel, in Kursen und Übersetzungskursen und du hast die Grammatik gelernt und so weiter. Aber dann kommst du nach Ägypten und die Leute gucken dich mit großen Augen an, was du da für ein komisches Gestell des Zeitungsarabischs sprichst und dann lernst du deren Dialekt. Aber das sind teilweise komplett andere Wörter, die die verwenden zum Beispiel.
Aber das ist dann das Zeitungsarabisch. Also das ist dann sozusagen auch das, was in den Medien verwendet wird.
Das Hocharabisch, was du an der Uni lernst, ist das, was in der Zeitung verwendet wird, was die die Sprecher im Fernsehen oder im Radio verwenden, aber was teilweise selbst für die, ich sag mal, die einfachen Leute in den arabischen Ländern selber teilweise schwer zu verstehen ist. Also, weil die lernen das in der Schule.
Welche Funktion hat dann dieses Hocharabisch? Ist das eher einigend oder eher teilend?
Ich glaube, tendenziell würde man eher sagen einigend, weil wenn du an der Uni Hocharabisch gelernt hast, hast du halt schon die Chance, in verschiedenen Ländern verstanden zu werden. Hängt halt vom Bildungsstand der Leute ab, mit denen du dich dann tatsächlich unterhältst. Aber wenn das jemand ist, der zum Beispiel regelmäßig Radio hört, Fernsehen guckt, Zeitung liest, dann wirst du auch mit deinem komisch gestellten Hocharabisch von den Leuten in verschiedenen Ländern verstanden werden. Während, wenn du nur einen bestimmten Dialekt sprichst, hängt das davon ab, welcher das ist. Beim Ägyptischen hast du Glück, dass der ägyptische Dialekt in fast der ganzen arabischen Welt verstanden wird, weil Ägypten so ein Film- und Fernsehzentrum ist und die halt ganz viele Filme exportieren, schon seit Jahrzehnten immer. Ja, mehr oder weniger, genau. Und deswegen verstehen alle Leute den ägyptischen Dialekt. Die hören das sofort, aber das sind halt die Filme, die sie konsumieren und die sie gucken und wissen, aha, okay, das ist das amerikanische, das englische dominiert. Und deswegen, wenn du mit ägyptischen Dialekt ankommst, dann verstehen nicht die Leute mit einer sehr hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit auch in anderen Ländern. Aber vielleicht verstehst du die da nicht. Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel, ich glaube als einer der schwierigsten arabischen Dialekte gilt, das ist Marokkanische, weil da viel auch noch Berbersprachen mit eingeflossen sind und es dann so eine Mischung aus Berbersprachen, arabisch, französisch. Beim tunesischen Dialekt habe ich das Gefühl, sind bestimmt locker 40 Prozent in jedem Satz sind französisch im tunesischen. Wenn man das einmal sich da reingehört hat, ist das relativ einfach, aber man muss erstmal darauf eingestellt sein, dass man in einem arabischen Satz nach französischen Wörtern Ausschau halten muss, weil sonst versteht man das auch nicht. Also da gibt es schon sehr, sehr große Unterschiede.
Also man kann auf jeden Fall festhalten, es gibt schon so eine Art Lingua Franca, die sich aber im Wesentlichen in den Medien abspielt.
Und in der Bildungselite, ja.
Und in der Bildungselite, aber in jedem Land ist es dann doch schon mal so deutlich anders gefärbt. Das heißt, wenn jetzt ein Mitglied des einen Landes den Dialekt eines anderen hört, dann ist die Zuordnung unproblematisch.
Du hörst ganz schnell, ob jemand aus dem Libanon kommt oder aus Syrien, du hörst sofort, ob jemand aus Ägypten oder Tunesien kommt, ob jemand eher von der arabischen Halbinsel kommt. Selbst innerhalb eines Landes gibt es dann nochmal Unterschiede bei den Dialekten. Saudi-Arabien, wo ich jetzt war, ist ein sehr großes Land und da gibt es auch nochmal sehr große Unterschiede im Dialekt innerhalb dieses Landes. Aber das kennen wir ja aus Deutschland auch. Auch in Deutschland hast du Norddeutsch, Sächsisch, Schwäbisch und Bayerisch zum Beispiel innerhalb von einem Land.
Jetzt ist es ja so mit der Wahrnehmung dieses gesamten, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das nennen soll, Regionen trifft es irgendwie gar nicht. Es ist ja ein Kulturraum. Der sich, klang jetzt schon an, im Prinzip von Marokko über die nordafrikanische Mittelmeerküste eben bis Saudi-Arabien, Oman, Jemen erstreckt und dann eben noch nach oben, mindestens bis Syrien. Türkei ist eine andere Welt schon, grenzt an, hat Überschneidungen.
Würde ich als Grenzregion dieses Kulturraumes sehen, gehört aber noch dazu. Ich meine, nach Osten kannst du es halt auch noch erweitern. Es hört ja nicht beim Golf auf. Iran gehört da noch dazu. Du kannst im weiteren Sinne auch noch Afghanistan und Pakistan dazu rechnen.
Dann kann Persien dazu zählen zum arabischen Raum.
Ja gut, nicht zum arabischen Raum. Aber das ist dann die Frage, was ist arabischer Raum? Also wenn du zum Beispiel das Wort Arabien verwendest, ganz konkret bezeichnet das eigentlich nur die arabische Halbinsel. Und zum Beispiel Nordafrika nicht. Und alles, was nördlich von Saudi-Arabien ist, eigentlich auch schon nicht mehr. Das heißt, da würden Syrien, Libanon, Jordanien, Irak, würden zu Arabien, dem eigentlichen Arabien, nicht mehr dazu gehören. Wenn du jetzt aber den Raum definierst, zum Beispiel als Länder, die durch die islamische Religion geprägt sind, zum Beispiel, dann würde ich auf jeden Fall Persien, Afghanistan, Pakistan, Bangladesch und auch noch, weiß ich nicht, Indonesien, Malaysia dazu rechnen.
Ja gut, das ist dann Islam. Das habe ich jetzt mal bewusst nicht verwendet, sondern eben schon Arabien, weil es ja auch, wenn man ein bisschen, ich bin echt nicht geschichtsfest, aber wenn man halt zumindest sich die Auseinandersetzungen der letzten fünf, sechs Jahrzehnte anschaut, war ja auch mal viel geprägt von dieser Chimäre des arabischen Einheits.
Pan-Arabismus.
Genau, sehr schön. Der Pan-Arabismus, also sozusagen so diese Idee, oder zumindest die Vorstellung, einzelner Führer da in irgendeiner Form eine Einigung herbeizuführen, das gab es ja in Ägypten und sicherlich auch noch in einigen anderen arabischen Ländern, was so ein bisschen, ja, wahrscheinlich ähnliche Probleme hat, wie unser Pan-Europäismus, der ja auch so seine Schwierigkeiten hat, auch wenn man sagen kann, der ist in gewisser Hinsicht schon noch ein bisschen weitergekommen. Das ist ja so eine Vorstellung von einem gemeinsamen Kultur- und Sprachraum, der musste sich ja dann auch irgendwo heraus ableiten. Also was, wenn Arabien eigentlich nur diese Halbinsel war, wie hat sich das dann sozusagen so als Idee verbreitert? Ist das jetzt wirklich nur so eine politische These, einzelner gewesen?
Das kannst du schon auf Sprache und Religion ganz stark zurückführen. Also, da alle diese Länder ja doch sehr stark durch den Islam geprägt sind und sich sehr stark darüber definieren, nicht nur darin, wie sich der Einzelne zu seiner Religion fühlt, sondern das hat sich ja auch niedergeschlagen auf die Verfassungen der Länder, auf deren Rechtsprechung, auf den Alltag, einfach darauf, wie die Kultur und die Traditionen geformt sind, gibt es da ja schon gemeinsame religiös geprägte Traditionen und Kulturpraktiken, auf die die Leute alle zurückgreifen. Ich glaube, dass das schon ein wichtiges verbindendes Element auf jeden Fall ist. Weil wenn du dir anguckst, der Islam, der in Saudi-Arabien entstanden ist und sich dann ausgebreitet hat in den Nahen und Mittleren Osten, dann ist er ja auch in Ägypten, hat sich nach Ägypten ganz stark ausgeprägt. Ägypten war lange Zeit auch ein Kulturzentrum für dieses frühe islamische Reich, genauso wie zum Beispiel Irak. Bagdad war ganz lange so ein Wissens- und Kulturzentrum. Also da gibt es ja eine Geschichte sozusagen, so ein Gefühl von, es gab mal eine Zeit, wo es ein großes islamisches Reich gab, das Goldene Zeitalter, und da waren wir alle Teil dieses großen Raumes. Aber ich würde trotzdem sagen, dieser pan-arabische Traum, der ist schon lange vorbei. Ja, das war der Geist der Zeit damals. Hatte auch so ein bisschen mit dem arabischen Sozialismus zu tun, aber das ist long over. Also das hat auch schon damals nicht richtig gut funktioniert. Und heute ist, glaube ich, der Nationalismus in den einzelnen Ländern wieder sehr viel stärker ausgeprägt. Auch weil es natürlich viele Beziehungen gibt.
Ja genau, also wenn es diesen Pan-Arabismus, wenn das einfach sozusagen nicht existent ist, dann frage ich mich wiederum, wie weit entfernt sind diese Länder voneinander? Wie weit ist ein Marokko von einem Syrien, ein Yim von einer Türkei? Also sind das einfach schon gar nicht mehr vergleichbare Welten? Oder ist durch die gemeinsame Religion und Sprache auch so ein kulturelles Bindeglied da ist, wo, sagen wir mal, sich jeder überall auf eine bestimmte Art wohlfühlen kann?
Ich glaube, das kann man, das ja und nein. Das hängt, glaube ich, immer davon ab, womit du das vergleichst. Also wenn du jetzt eine beliebige Person aus Marokko, zum Beispiel, eine beliebige Person aus Syrien nimmst und die in einen Raum sperrs würden, die wahrscheinlich dir sehr viele Dinge erzählen können, was sie alles nicht gemeinsam haben, wahrscheinlich hätten sie auch noch Schwierigkeiten, sich zu verständigen, weil einfach ihre Dialekte sehr unterschiedlich sind, weil ihre Lebensrealitäten sehr unterschiedlich sind und sie würden, glaube ich, eher das Gefühl haben, dass sie nicht besonders viel miteinander gemeinsam haben. Wenn du jetzt aber zum Beispiel diese beiden Personen in Deutschland in eine Flüchtlingsunterkunft steckst und die beiden feststellen, dass sie die einzigen in dem ganzen Haus sind, die die Gebetszeiten einhalten, fünfmal am Tag, hätten sie plötzlich das Gefühl, dass sie im Verhältnis zu allen anderen vielleicht mehr gemeinsam haben. Das hängt wirklich immer davon ab, was die Vergleichsgröße sozusagen ist. Und was natürlich auch dazu gehört, wie wenn du Leute aus beliebigen Ländern miteinander vergleichst, es hat auch immer viel mit der sozialen Schicht zu tun. Dass natürlich, sagen wir mal, zwei Leute, die in sehr erblichen Verhältnissen leben, in Syrien oder Marokko, möglicherweise in ihrem Alltag mehr miteinander gemeinsam haben als jeweils mit jemandem, der sehr reich ist in einem ihrer eigenen Länder.
Also man hat das dann auch in Europa auch nicht so anders gemacht.
Genau, das hast du da ja auch gemacht.
Also im wesentlichen Verhältnis ist es dann eine Äquivalenz. Jetzt hast du dieses Studium gemacht, Islamwissenschaften als Master. Wie lange werkelt man an so etwas?
Also eigentlich ist ein Masterstudiengang darauf ausgelegt, nur zwei Jahre zu dauern. Bachelor dauert eigentlich drei Jahre. Ich habe meinen Bachelor auch in Regel Studienzeit gemacht. Master eigentlich zwei Jahre, wobei bei dem Master, den ich gemacht habe, einem schon nahegelegt wird, auch noch mal einen Auslandsaufenthalt irgendwo reinzuschieben, dass sich das im Master anbietet, um eben die Sprachkenntnisse noch mehr auszubessern und einfach auch mal ein Gefühl für den Raum zu bekommen, den man da studiert. Das habe ich dann auch gemacht und war eben ein Jahr in Ägypten, 2009, 2010 in der Mitte. Und dann habe ich am Ende noch ein bisschen länger mit meiner Masterarbeit gebraucht. Also ich glaube, ich habe statt der zwei Jahre, vier Jahre gebraucht für meinen Master.
Aber so.
Also ich würde sagen, insgesamt mit Bachelor und Master habe ich dann auch nicht länger gebraucht, als manche Leute, die Magister oder Diplom studiert haben.
Aber deine Reise, hast du jetzt gesagt, deine Reise nach Ägypten war im Prinzip Teil des Studiums?
Ja genau, ich habe das in der Mitte gemacht. Ich habe da einfach zwei Urlaubssemester genommen. Da zieht auch keiner die Augenbrauen hoch, weil das wie gesagt üblich ist, wenn man so regional Wissenschaften studiert oder auf eine Region fokussiert ist. Ich habe zwei Urlaubssemester genommen, was total unproblematisch war und habe einfach ein Jahr lang in Kairo, an der Kairo University einen Sprachkurs gemacht, also an der Uni.
Das heißt, da hast du eigentlich das erste Mal wirklich intensiv auch dich mit der Sprache dauerhaft auseinander gesetzt.
Genau, also das in Kairo, der Sprachkurs, den ich gemacht habe, das war zwar wieder hocharabisch und hat sozusagen das nochmal intensiviert und vertieft, was ich auch in Deutschland an der Uni schon gelernt hatte. Aber in Kairo hatte ich natürlich die Gelegenheit, sozusagen die Sprache der Straße zu lernen, was die Leute da so sprechen. Weil dann fährst du halt Taxi und musst jemandem erklären, wo du lang möchtest oder du hast Behördengänge und musst dich irgendwie verständlich machen. Du gehst in Restaurants, du triffst Leute auf der Straße, mit denen du dich unterhältst.
Aber du hast dann auch nichts anderes gemacht, als aus der Sprache studiert und unterleben.
Genau, unterleben. Das ist ehrlich gesagt anstrengend genug. Ja, wirklich. Das ist nicht einfach. Das ist nicht einfach, ein Jahr in Ägypten zu leben. Ich habe zwar auch Zeit gehabt für mich, was ich auch gut fand. Ich habe auch viele Bücher gelesen in dem Jahr, die ich schon immer mal lesen wollte. Aber das Leben in Ägypten ist wirklich extrem anstrengend. Also wenn die Leute mich gefragt haben, nachdem ich wieder da war, wie war es denn, wie war denn ja in Kairo, dann habe ich das so in einem Satz zusammengefasst und habe gesagt, es war sehr interessant, aber es war auch sehr anstrengend. Ehrlich gesagt, das Gleiche sage ich jetzt auch. Ich bin ja gerade wieder gekommen nach zwei Jahren Saudi-Arabien. Und die Leute sagen, und ein Satz, wie war Saudi-Arabien? Und dann sage ich genau das Gleiche. Es war super interessant, aber es war auch sehr anstrengend, obwohl es komplett unterschiedliche Erfahrungen waren. Also es waren ganz unterschiedliche Arten von anstrengend.
Ich war mal eine Woche in Marokko.
Ja, ich merk schon, das siehst du, wovon ich rede. Also es ist nicht einfach. Also ich mein, Cairo ist schon so eine Stadt, die kann einen wirklich unfassbar erschlagen. Es ist ja schon allein unklar, wie viele Menschen da eigentlich leben. Also es wird immer geschätzt, irgendwas zwischen 10 und 20 Millionen. Es ist eine riesige Stadt. Du hast immer das Gefühl, diese ungefähr 20 Millionen Menschen wollen immer alle genau an dem Ort sein, wo du auch gerade bist, egal ob du die Straße runtergehst oder in einem Aufzug stehst oder in einem Bus oder so. Die Luftverschmutzung ist super krass. 2009, 2010 war ich da. Noch nicht so lange, ja. Aber ich war jetzt auch 2014 noch mal da für einen Monat, bevor ich nach Saudi-Arabien gegangen bin. Und ich war jetzt auch gerade Anfang März, also vor einem Monat. Genau vor einem Monat war ich auch noch mal für eine Woche in Kairo. Ich muss sagen, da hab ich auch nach zwei Jahren Saudi-Arabien, wo ich jetzt wieder eine Woche in Kairo war, hab ich echt gedacht, wie hab ich das jemals ausgehalten, da ein Jahr zu leben, weil ich das so anstrengend fand.
Du warst im Prinzip so mehr oder weniger das letzte Jahr von dem Arabischen Frühling da.
2011 war der Arabische Frühling.
Also du bist weggegangen und alles fiel auseinander.
Genau, also könnte man so sagen, das Gleiche war ja auch, als ich in Syrien war. Ich war im Frühling 2011 in Syrien und als ich da weggegangen bin, ist auch alles auseinandergefallen. Man könnte sagen, I bring chaos in my wake.
Es soll Leute geben, die so sehr den Regen anziehen, dass sie sich von bestimmten Gemeinden dafür bezahlen lassen, dass sie da nicht Urlaub machen. Das wär vielleicht für dich auch noch mal...
Also lass uns jetzt mal einen Blick auf Saudi-Arabien werfen und gucken, was da in den nächsten Monaten und Jahren passiert. Weiß man nicht, ja.
Aber vielleicht noch mal kurz Ägypten, dass man sich das so ein bisschen vorstellen kann, vor allem dieses Anstrengen. Also ich hab jetzt so einen Eindruck, aber ich vermute auch mal grad als Frau ist der Bereich anstrengend, noch mal in einer anderen Dimension. Was geschieht, wie... Können wir da mal so durch so einen Tag gehen?
Okay, also wie gesagt, Cairo ist einfach als Stadt schon total überwältigend, weil es einfach so voll ist. Du bist einfach immerzu von Sinneseindrücken erschlagen. Die Luftverschmutzung ist total krass. Man hat die ganze Zeit so permanent so ein bisschen Halsschmerzen, einfach von einem Smog.
Das ist vielleicht ganz gut für diese Würgellaute.
Aber auch sehr anstrengend auf Dauer. Es ist super laut. Du hast mega viel Lärm die ganze Zeit. Der Verkehr erschlägt dich. Es ist immer Rush-Auer, immer, überall. Es ist immer voll. Es sind immer Menschen. Du drängst dich immer durch Menschenmassen. Wenn du die Straße runtergehst, wenn du im Supermarkt bist, wenn du mit der U-Bahn fährst, es sind immer unfassbar viele Menschen um dich rum. Du hast diese vielen Gerüche, diese vielen Geräusche. Die Leute sind auch sehr laut, wenn sie miteinander reden auf der Straße. Man muss sich erstmal ein bisschen dran gewöhnen, dass wenn man das Gefühl hat, dass Leute sich anschreien, dass die sich gar nicht anschreien oder streiten, sondern dass sie sich einfach nur sehr leidenschaftlich was mitteilen. Das sind einfach so Sinneseindrücke, die man erstmal, die man sich gewöhnen muss.
Das ist, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen unsere Wahrnehmung von arabischen Menschen.
Dass sie sich laut und aufgebracht sehen.
Ja, dass sie so eine Lautheit mit sich bringen, die vielleicht uns nicht unbedingt immer so liegt.
Aber das ist auch was, woran man sich gewöhnt. Also ich habe jetzt, ich merke jetzt immer, wenn ich länger im arabischen Ausland war und zurück nach Deutschland komme, ich habe auch immer so einen kleinen Reverse-Culture-Shock, also dass ich mich dann wundere, warum die Leute hier so still sind. Es geht immer, na ja, oder auch so unfreundlich einfach und so unherzlich. Also es geht im Prinzip los, ich war, nein, wirklich.
Ich weiß, du bist zurückgekommen und du hast irgendwas über den Bus getwittert.
Ja, es ist immer so. Das ist eine Standard-Situation, es ist ein Klischee und das passiert mir jedes einzelne Mal.
Ich hab dann genau dasselbe gehabt.
Tim, das passiert mir jedes Mal. Ich komme vom Flughafen und ich steige in den Bus vom Flughafen in die Stadt und der Himmel über mir ist grau und es ist Berlin und die Leute im Bus motzen sich an. Der Busfahrer motzt die Leute an, warum sie nicht durchgehen und die Leute motzen sich gegenseitig an, warum sie im Weg stehen und alles ist irgendwie grau und blöd und die Leute gucken sauer.
Ich kam aus Mexiko zurück und der Busfahrer motzte gerade einen Radfahrer an mit dem Satz, was denn hast du doch eben mit mir auch gemacht?
Und das ist Reverse Culture Shock. Ich frage, warum sind die Leute eigentlich so krantig hier immer?
Ja, das wiederum hast du da so jetzt in der Form nicht gehabt.
Nee, also die Leute reden irgendwie laut und leidenschaftlich miteinander und man nimmt das vielleicht als aufgebracht wahr, aber es ist auch eine ganz ganz andere Herzlichkeit, die ich hier nicht so kenne, die mir dann auch so ein bisschen fehlt. Da sind ganz viel so, da sind wir wieder bei Sprache, so Floskeln oder Höflichkeiten, dass du irgendwo hingehst und jemanden triffst, weiß ich nicht, in einem Restaurant oder an einem Schalter oder sonst irgendwo und es geht damit los, dass du die Person erstmal, vielleicht so ein bisschen wie im Englischen dieses how do you do, dass du erstmal sagst, wie geht's? Also bevor irgendwie das eigentliche Gespräch losgeht oder dein eigenes Anliegen kommt, tauscht man erstmal freundliche, herzliche Floskeln aus, aber die ja trotzdem irgendwie was bedeuten. So und ich finde, das haben wir, wir sind ja, wir Deutsche gelten ja ohnehin halt sehr direkt. Aber diese sehr, sehr vielen, sehr herzlichen Floskeln, die sind mir zum Beispiel sehr ans Herz gewachsen. Also es ist zum Beispiel extrem viele Varianten gibt, wie man einen Dank abwehren kann. Also jemand bedankt sich bei dir und du kannst auf sehr, sehr viele verschiedene Arten sagen, hey, du musst dich doch nicht bedanken, das war doch selbstverständlich. Also weiß ich nicht, haben wir zehn verschiedene Arten, das im Deutschen auszudrücken? Also da gibt's sowas wie... Die Norddeutschen würden vielleicht sagen, dafür nicht. So und damit war's das auch schon. Ich weiß nicht, ob mir viele andere deutsche Formulierungen einfallen, die das ausdrücken.
Passt schon.
Kein Problem, gern geschehen. Aber das ist ja irgendwie so ein bisschen unaufgeregt. Und im Arabischen ist das sehr blumig.
Verstehe, mehr Protokoll.
Genau und das finde ich irgendwie ganz nett. Aber zurück zu Kairo, wo alles laut ist und die Grüche und die Stimmen und die Sinnesindrücke auf einen einschützen. Ich habe gewohnt in Doi. Das ist, wenn man die Karte von Kairo vor dem geistigen Auge hat, dann fließt der Nil da so einmal durch. Und auf der linken Nilseite, so das ganze Viertel, auf der linken Nilseite wird so grob Gizeh genannt. Also da, wo auch die Pyramiden sind. Alles, was links vom Nil ist. Und ziemlich genau, wenn man einmal den Nil überquert hat auf der linken Seite, ist das Viertel.
Aber eben was für eine Art...
Achso, was für eine Art Viertel.
Also was für eine Art Behausung auch.
Achso, ich hab in der WG gewohnt, im siebten Stock, mit anderen jungen Menschen, teilweise Deutsche, Amerikaner, einmal auch mit einer Ägypterin. So Leute, die in meinem Alter waren und studiert oder gearbeitet haben. Es gibt alle möglichen Wohnungen, die vermietet werden, die dann irgendeinem Landlord oder eine Landlady gehören. Du hast auch in Ländern wie in Ägypten oder Saudi-Arabien auch Craigslist oder Mailinglisten. Ich kannte Leute, die auch schon mal ein Auslandsjahr in Ägypten gemacht hatten und hatte von denen teilweise noch Kontakte oder wusste, wie man das so macht. Aber du kannst solche Sachen erst klären, wenn du vor Ort bist. Also am Anfang habe ich mit einer Freundin, die Halb-Ägypterin ist, in einer Wohnung ihrer Familie gewohnt die erste Woche. Dann gehst du halt auf WG-Suche und das ist nicht so viel anders, als hier in Berlin. Du guckst halt auf der Mailing-Liste, schreibst die Leute an, sagst, ok, Dienstag um drei kommst du vorbei, guck dir die Wohnung an, das sind die Konditionen.
Wie im richtigen Leben.
Wie im richtigen Leben, genau. Und dann findest du halt eine WG über Freunde oder Leute, die du kennst oder so. Genau. Ja, dann bin ich in so einem WG-Zimmer gewohnt. Das war auch ein nettes Viertel, gut an die U-Bahn angebunden. Es gibt in Kairo drei U-Bahn-Linien. Seit sehr, sehr vielen Jahren wird davon geredet, dass die vierte bald gebaut wird, aber ich glaube, es wird nie passieren. Genau. Und schon, wenn man aus dem Haus geht, also erstens mal, was ägyptische Häuser haben oder auch in vielen anderen arabischen Ländern, die haben einen Bawab oder eine Bawaba, das ist das, was man im französischen Concierge nennen würde. Also im Haus wohnt immer jemand, der einfach so Hausmeister quasi ist, aber in so einem Land auch noch viele andere Dienste übernimmt. Also das ist jemand, der sitzt quasi am Eingang und hat auch so eine kleine Wohnung mit der Familie, direkt am Eingang. Der guckt, wer so rein und rausgeht, fegt irgendwie den Staub vor der Straße, vor der Haustür weg, repariert die Briefkästen. Wenn du sagst, du brauchst irgendwie eine Gasflasche ausgetauscht, dann kommt der. Du kannst den aber auch für andere kleine Aufgaben beauftragen. Das ist so ein bisschen da.
Der wird vom Haus bezahlt.
Ja, oder den bezahlst du mit. Also das gehört quasi mit zu deiner Monatsmiete, dass jeder im Haus dem so nur bloß bezahlt. Das hat im Prinzip jedes Haus. Das heißt, du gehst erstmal an dein Bawab oder deine Bawaba vorbei. Bei mir war das wirklich so, was ich meine, wenn ich sage, dass ich Ägypten so anstrengend fand. Ich gehe durch den Hausflur und bevor ich auf die Straße trete, atme ich noch ein allerletztes Mal so tief durch und drücke den Rücken durch, bevor ich auf die Straße gehe. Weil es wirklich einen extrem großen Unterschied gibt, das habe ich wirklich in der arabischen Welt das erste Mal so erlebt zwischen dem privaten und dem öffentlichen Raum. Der öffentliche Raum ist in Ägypten extrem anstrengend, aber auch in Saudi-Arabien auf eine gewisse Art und Weise. Und da gelten bestimmte Spielregeln, da musst du auf bestimmte Sachen aufmerksam sein, auf die du zum Beispiel in Deutschland nicht aufmerksam bist, wie du dich verhältst als Frau im öffentlichen Raum, welche Sachen sind angemessen, wo gehst du lang, der Verkehr läuft anders, mit wem redest du wie oder auch nicht. Du bist einfach auf andere Sachen aufmerksam. Gerade in Ägypten wirst du einfach die ganze Zeit auch angesprochen und belästigt, das ist jetzt in Saudi-Arabien nicht so der Fall. Aber das macht es einfach sehr, sehr anstrengend. Du kannst nicht 100 Meter von deiner Wohnung bis zum Supermarkt runtergehen, ohne einmal angesprochen zu werden, als weiße europäische Frau. Naja, je nachdem, worin du dich wohlfühlst. Also ich hatte westliche Freundinnen, die einfach auch so T-Shirts getragen haben. Zum Beispiel, ich hab glaube ich in einem Jahr in Ägypten, ich hab nicht ein einziges Mal ein T-Shirt auf der Trasse getragen. Ich hab immer lange Sachen getragen, egal wie heiß es war. Ich mein, es machen ägyptischen Frauen auch, also es ist halt heiß. Nee, weil du was kommunizieren möchtest über deine Kleidung. Also ich hab lange Sachen getragen, lange Ärmel, lange Hosenbeine und meistens auch noch Oberteile, die so über den Hintern drüber gehen. Ich persönlich, wenn ich solche Sachen trage. Ich versuch dadurch so eine gewisse Seriöslichkeit zu kommunizieren und vielleicht auch den Leuten so ein bisschen zu kommunizieren. Man muss zugeben, viele Leute haben doch so ein Bild von der westlichen Frau, das sie aus Hollywood-Filmen bekommen haben, was nicht, was sehr klischeemäßig und sehr monolithisch ist und denken, westliche Frauen sind so und so und die sind ganz anders als arabische Frauen. Die haben keine Morals und die kann man, also für die macht das keinen Unterschied sozusagen, mit wem sie ins Bett gehen und dann könnte ich die ja jetzt, da könnte ich ja auch mal einen Hintern fassen, weil das macht ja keinen Unterschied. Und in dem ich versuche, zum Beispiel mich so zu kleiden, aber auch im konkreten Umgang mit den Menschen, wenn ich arabisch rede, aber auch bestimmte Verhaltensweisen einhalte, versuche ich zu kommunizieren, dass ich eher mich in dem moralischen Mindset von denen sehe und dementsprechend auch behandelt werden möchte. Also zum Beispiel eine Sache ist, dass es mir super häufig in Ägypten passiert, und auch vielen von meinen Freundinnen, dass junge ägyptische Männer einen ungefragt fotografieren. Zum Beispiel in der U-Bahn oder sonst irgendwo. Manchmal versuchen sie noch, das unauffällig zu machen. Manchmal auch nicht. Und es wäre mir in Deutschland fast egal, weil es in Deutschland nichts bedeutet. Aber in der arabischen Welt hast du halt das Ding, das steht ja auch in jedem Reiseführer, keine arabischen Frauen fotografieren, bevor du sie nicht gefragt hast und auf jeden Fall immer ganz vorsichtig sein, weil das sonst als offensiv wahrgenommen wird. Und ich muss sagen, ich empfinde das als offensiv, wenn ich weiß, dass in der Kultur, in der ich bin, dass arabische Frauen sich das nicht bieten lassen würden oder ihre Männer sich das nicht bieten lassen würden, dass man sie einfach fotografiert. Dass aber davon ausgegangen wird, dass es bei mir als westlicher Frau ja kein Problem ist, weil ich falle ja ja komplett raus.
Weil du bist ja quasi Freiwild.
Mehr oder weniger. Und deswegen habe ich immer ein ziemliches Tamtam gemacht, wenn ich gemerkt habe, dass jemand mich ungefragt fotografiert habe und bin dahingegangen und habe auf Arabisch gesagt, ich möchte nicht, dass du Fotos von mir machst. Lass das sein. Und das ist etwas Ähnliches, was ich versuche durch die lange Kleidung zu kommunizieren. Ich möchte, dass du mich respektierst im Rahmen der moralischen Wertvorstellungen, die du besitzt, die ich auch respektiere, indem ich mich z.B. dementsprechend kleide und so verhalte. Aber dann will ich eben auch...
Ja, wenn du versuchst, dasselbe in Anspruch zu nehmen, was für die anderen auch gilt, wird das dann auch akzeptiert. Ich meine, die fallen wahrscheinlich erst mal vom Stuhl, wenn du sie auf Arabisch anquatschst, oder?
Aber ich muss sagen, dass ich... Ich meine, die Leute, die Frauen, handeln das ganz unterschiedlich und haben auch sehr viele unterschiedliche Erfahrungen gemacht. Und ich kann da wirklich nur für mich persönlich sprechen, wie ich persönlich das Hand habe. Und ich muss sagen, dass das für mich sehr gut funktioniert hat. Also, dass ich... Und dass mir das auch wichtig ist und dass ich mich damit wohlfühle, wenn ich den Leuten kommuniziere. Ich respektiere euer Wertsystem und ich erwarte, dass ich dafür auch den Respekt bekomme. Und das funktioniert relativ gut. Und das verstehen die auch ziemlich schnell. Das merkst du dann auch über so Sachen. Es gab ja neulich auch wieder so eine Debatte über, wie man zum Beispiel die Hand gibt. Ich hab kein Problem damit, wenn ich weiß... Also, ich hab kein Problem damit, jemandem nicht so offensiv die Hand zu geben, wie ich das zum Beispiel in Deutschland machen würde. Ich achte dann einfach darauf. Ich mach das dann einfach erstmal nicht. Und verhalte mich zurückhaltender fremden Männern gegenüber, mit denen ich mich unterhalte. Taxifahrern, weiß nicht, die Leute, die mir einen Zugticket verkaufen... Naja, es geht einfach darum, dass du als Mann und Frau, die sich nicht kennen, erst mal eine größere Distanz zueinander hältst. So. Und das mach ich dann einfach auch. Und das funktioniert dann auch gut. Ich hab zum Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt bei der Belästigung im öffentlichen Raum sind, die ich in Ägypten als extrem stark empfunden habe, in Saudi-Arabien hatte ich das fast gar nicht. Das Drollste, was mir passiert ist in Saudi-Arabien, ist, dass wenn ich eine Straße lang gehe oder an der Straßenecke stehe und auf den Taxi warte, dass jemand in seinem Auto sehr, sehr langsam an mir vorbeifährt und große Stielaugen macht und vielleicht das Fenster runterlässt und mir was zuruft. Aber das ist dann auch nicht aggressiv absurd, nicht aggressiv obszön, wie das in Ägypten häufig der Fall war, sondern das ist dann eher so was freundlich aufgeregtes, so was wie, oh mein Gott, eine ausländische westliche Frau. Das ist ja verrückt, wenn ich das meinen Kumpels erzähle. Aber das ist nicht so aggressiv und fühlt sich nicht so bedrohlich an. Und manchmal fährt der dann vielleicht bis zum Ende der Straße, macht einen U-Turn und fährt nochmal an mir vorbei, weil er das irgendwie so aufregend fand. Aber in so einer Situation zum Beispiel, wenn es mir dann auf die Nerven geht oder so, ich bleib dann stehen und dreh zum Beispiel mein Gesicht weg, weil ich in Saudi-Arabien mich zum Beispiel nicht verschleiert habe und kein Kopftuch trage. Aber ich halt trotzdem auch durch dieses Verhalten wieder kommuniziere. Hey, nicht, dass wir uns falsch verstehen. Ich bin auch eine Frau mit moralischen Wertvorstellungen. Und es ist nicht dein Platz mich jetzt hier irgendwie zu belästigen. Das ist nicht cool. Das würdest du mit anderen Frauen auch nicht machen. Und das verstehen die auch ganz schnell. Ich stehe dann da, guck kurz die Hauswand an. Der merkt das, okay, sie ist nicht interessiert und fährt weg. So. Und es funktioniert natürlich nicht immer. In Ägypten hab ich häufig auch das Problem gehabt. Das fand ich extrem anstrengend, extrem schwierig. Und es hat auch lange gedauert, nachdem ich wieder in Deutschland war, bis ich das mal so gründlich alles verarbeitet hatte, dass die Leute das manchmal nicht einsehen, dass ich dann kommuniziere oder auch so was sage, wie ich möchte gerne den Respekt, den du, also, ne? Ich komm auf dich zu und du kommst auf mich zu, was unser Verhalten angeht. Das ist häufig, wenn du dich dann verteidigst oder schimpfst, weil jemand dich belästigt hat oder so, dass du auf so ein Unverständnis drehst, hey, wieso stell ich mich da nicht so an? Und das find ich sehr, sehr schwer, damit umzugehen, weil dir dann quasi das Recht abgesprochen wird, dich zu verteidigen. Das ist nicht immer der Fall. Alle Menschen sind unterschiedlich. Ich hab Tausende verschiedene Situationen erlebt, aber du musst zum Beispiel in Ägypten auch damit rechnen, dass wenn du auf jemanden schimpfst und sagst, es fällt dir ein, mir in den Hintern zu fassen, dass der dir irgendwas Obscönes, Aggressives antwortet. Oder dass du, wenn du jemanden haust, also es muss jetzt gar nicht schmerzhaft sein, aber einfach, wenn du jemanden zurückpuschst, schubst oder so, weil du findest, der hat dich unsittlich berührt, dass der dich zurückschubst oder dich zurückhaut. Das ist schon eine andere Welt. Also es ist man...
Es ist aber jetzt auch nicht so, dass das in Deutschland jetzt auch nicht nie...
Du, ich hab nicht in der gleichen Häufigkeit, aber ich hab vergleichbar unangenehme Dinge auch alle schon hier in Morbid erlebt, oder weiß ich nicht, irgendwo anders. Und das hat dann in dem Falle nichts mit dem Kulturraum zu tun. Deutsche Bauarbeiter können genauso obszön und unfreundlich sein und mir den Tag verhageln, weil die mir irgendwelche Dinge sagen, die ich nicht hören wollte, wie in anderen Teilen der Welt. Also das ist... Das erlebst du als Frau überall.
Ja, also eigentlich alles wie immer.
Alles wie immer, nur in einer anderen Sprache. So, nee, aber du hast natürlich in Ägypten... Es ist eine andere Intensität. Es ist eine andere Intensität, eine andere Häufung und du hast halt auch nicht nur... Es ist ja auch nicht alle Interaktionssituationen, die du hast, wenn du jetzt auf dem Weg von deiner Wohnung zum Supermarkt bist. Das ist ja nicht alles sexuelle Belästigung. Manche rufen dir auch einfach nur freundlich zu, hallo, guten Morgen, herzlich willkommen in Ägypten. Oder möchtest du nicht mein Souvenir kaufen? Weil du natürlich sofort, du wirst ja wahrgenommen als Fremdkörper. Also ich kann meine weiße Haut nicht verstecken, jeder sieht sofort, dass ich keine Ägypterin bin. Und ich kann das niemals ausstellen. Ich kann niemals, egal wie ich mich anziehe oder wie ich mich verhalte, ich kann niemals so mit dem Hintergrund verschmelzen, dass ich nicht mehr als Ausländerin wahrgenommen werde. Und manche Leute wollen mir halt auch einfach was verkaufen oder mir was erzählen oder sonst irgendwie Kontakt aufnehmen. Und das muss nicht immer aggressiv sein oder mit sexueller Belästigung zu tun. Aber es wird dir sehr, sehr viel Interaktion aufgezwungen, die du nicht haben möchtest. Und die du in Deutschland nicht hast, wenn du die Straße runtergehst, weil du einfach irgendeine ex-belebige Person bist, die die Leute nicht ansprechen.
Was würdest du jetzt noch sagen, ist auffällig so in deinem Tagesablauf in Ägypten gewesen? Was jenseits der Dichte der Straßen, kannst du dich da gut organisieren?
Ja, doch, also, man, ich hab immer das Gefühl, so fremde Großstädte sind so ein bisschen wie wilde Pferde, die man zähmt. Am Anfang ist das alles sehr überfordernd und man wird häufig abgeworfen und man verläuft sich und man verzweifelt und alles ist sehr schwierig. Aber im Laufe der Zeit kennst du irgendwie deine Ecken, du weißt, wo die U-Bahn langfährt, du kannst, du kennst die Taxipreise, du kannst dem Taxifahrer sagen, wo er langfahren soll und du fühlst dich dann irgendwie insgesamt wohler und sicherer und hast das Gefühl, du hast das zu deinem Kiez gemacht oder hast das zu deiner Stadt gemacht. Ich muss sagen, das ist auch etwas, was ich sehr schätze. Das sind so Herausforderungen, die ich immer wieder gerne annehme. So fremde Städte zu zähmen, die sich am Anfang sehr fremd anfühlen.
Kairo ist jetzt deine Hood?
Kairo ist meine Hood, aber Jidda zum Beispiel, Saudi-Arabien ist auch meine Hood. Das fühlt sich cooler an auch am Ende, wenn du sagst, ich kenn mich hier aus, ich weiß, wo alles ist. Wenn jemand sagt, ich müsste eigentlich mal das und das kaufen, dann sagst du, ich kenn genau den Laden für dich. Der ist nämlich ganz versteckt dahinten, blablabla.
Was war denn für dich am unerwartetsten nach dem Jahr in Ägypten? Was sind denn so die Dinge, die du eigentlich dort erlebt hast, auf die du jetzt nicht so eingestellt warst? Dass das jetzt sozusagen als Frau in Cairo eine schwierige Herausforderung werden könnte, ich denke, das dürfte jetzt keine Neuigkeit gewesen sein.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es irgendwas gab, was ich so nicht vermutet hätte.
Oder was sich, sag mal, mal in einer anderen Intensität niedergeschlagen hat, als du das vielleicht gerechnet hast.
Naja, du, also, was man ja schon auch immer wieder sehr stark in den Ländern merkt, ich mein, das ist zwar was, was mir vorher bekannt war, aber es ist ja nochmal was anderes, ob einem Sachen bekannt sind und ob man sie dann im Alltag erlebt, ist ja zum Beispiel auch die extrem große Schere zwischen Arm und Reich. Du siehst es einfach, die Leute sind einfach krass viel ärmer so im Schnitt. Es gibt viel mehr Menschen, die viel, viel, viel ärmer sind und unfassbar wenig haben. Das geht schon los bei diesen Hausmeistern, von denen ich geredet hab, von diesen Bahwabs oder Bahwabas. Die wohnen teilweise mit ihrer Familie und fünf Kindern in einer Tiefgarage auf einem Bett. In einem Raum, der acht Quadratmeter hat. Das ist total krass. Du gehst da jeden Tag vorbei und du siehst das. Du kannst irgendwie auch versuchen, keine Ahnung, wenn du alte Kleider hast, die du weggibst oder irgendwas, das du nicht mehr brauchst, dann fragst du die natürlich als Erstes, ob die es gebrauchen können. Aber du wirst die ganze Zeit immer überall mit ganz krasser Armut konfrontiert. Und gleichzeitig gibt es auch Leute, die in verrücktem Reichtum leben und in irgendwelchen verrückten Clubs abhängen oder irgendwelchen super teuren, schicken Restaurants. Und dann kommst du zurück nach Deutschland und hast das Gefühl, okay, auch hier geht perspektivisch die Schere zwischen Arm und Reich weiter auseinander, aber du hast das Gefühl, dass alle sich immer noch mehr so sehr viel näher beieinander sind. Du hast nicht das Gefühl, dass es diesen verrückten Reichtum gibt, der dir, der sich umso obszöner anfühlt, wenn du gerade die Bettler auf der Straße gesehen hast. Und gerade in Ägypten ist es halt auch so, dass dadurch, dass du sehr, sehr viele Leute hast, die sehr, sehr arm sind, hat sich so eine Art Dienstleistungsgesellschaft entwickelt, wo noch die kleinste Tätigkeit eine ist, für die man irgendwie Geld verdienen kann oder Bakshish verdienen kann. Und wenn das ein kleiner Junge ist, der den Händlern in ihren Läden morgens Tee bringt oder die Parklücke freihält oder jemanden in die Parklücke reinwinkt oder den Fahrstuhl bedient oder also so kleine Tätigkeiten, wo du in Deutschland gar nicht drauf kommen würdest, dass das was ist.
Das mit der Parklücke erlebe ich jetzt hier auch von Zeit zu Zeit schon. Das sind so Elemente, die sich so langsam reinschleichen, die mich nicht deutlich ruhiger schlafen lassen, um ehrlich zu sein. Aber das ist natürlich da in einer ganz anderen Dimension, in einer ganz anderen Dichte. So kenne ich das auch aus Marokko. Also eine wilde Zeit hast du gehabt in Ägypten und bist dann wieder zurückgegangen. Und irgendwann hast du dann sozusagen dein Studium auch durchgebracht.
Und jetzt fragst du dich, wie ich nach Saudi Arabien gekommen bin.
Na ja, jetzt frage ich mich vor allem erstmal wieder, was bedeutet das dann, wenn man das sozusagen, nicht jeder versteht das Studium jetzt als unmittelbare Tätigkeitsvorlage. Aber du bist dann danach unmittelbar auch in dem Feld weiter voran marschiert, kann man das so sagen?
Ja, doch, mit meiner beruflichen Entwicklung. Ja schon, das war natürlich auch meine Hoffnung, als ich die Lab Wissenschaften studiert habe. Ich hab das studiert, weil mich das interessiert hat und weil ich Bock darauf hatte und Lust hatte, mich mit dem Kulturraum zu beschäftigen und Sprachen zu lernen und die Gelegenheit zu haben, in diese Länder zu reisen. Aber ich hatte natürlich auch die Hoffnung, und das hat sich auch schon damals abgezeichnet vor ein paar Jahren, dass das, wenn man Expertin für diesen Kulturraum wird, dass es in absehbarer Zeit immer noch Jobs geben wird für einen selbst. Und das ist jetzt natürlich umso wahrer, aber das war auch damals schon wahr. Deswegen war natürlich meine Hoffnung, irgendeinen Job zu finden, der irgendwas mit dem Kulturraum zu tun hat, wo ich sozusagen meine Fähigkeiten und Kenntnisse einbringen kann. Und das hat sich ja dann auch tatsächlich bewahrheitet. Ich bin dann Kulturmanagerin für die Robert-Bosch-Stiftung in Jeddah geworden. Es ging damit los, als ich erstmal nach Jobs in Berlin gesucht habe, aber damals nicht so besonders viele gefunden habe. Also wir sind jetzt zeitlich so 2014, Ende 2013, Anfang 2014. Ich hab mich in Berlin umgeguckt und nicht viel gefunden in meinem Bereich, in meiner Branche sozusagen, was gut bezahlt war, interessant gewesen wäre, wo man jetzt als Berufsanfänger nach dem Studium ohne nennenswerte Berufserfahrung hätte einsteigen können. Und dann kam dieser Job-Along, den ich gesehen habe in Saudi-Arabien, und der hat gut gepasst. Der hat auf meine Qualifikationen gepasst, auf meine Erfahrungen, meine Kenntnisse. Ich muss da noch kurz einschieben, ich war vorher schon mal in Saudi-Arabien gewesen während des Studiums 2009, im Februar 2009. Das war noch bevor ich für das Jahr nach Ägypten gegangen bin. Mein Institut an der Uni hat so eine Exkursion angeboten. Das machen die manchmal. Eigentlich hatten sie eine in den Jemen angeboten und ich wollte eigentlich in den Jemen, aber da waren schon alle Plätze voll. Und dann hat jemand gesagt, hey, aber wir machen auch eine nach Saudi-Arabien, willst du nicht damit fahren? Und da hab ich gedacht, auch warum nicht? Wann kommt man schon mal nach Saudi-Arabien? Und hab dann eben diese Uni-Exkursion gemacht. Das waren zehn Tage im Februar 2009 nach Saudi-Arabien. War das erste Mal da und es war tatsächlich das erste arabische Land, das ich besucht habe in meinem ganzen Leben. Es sind dann noch viele gefolgt danach, aber angefangen hab ich in Saudi-Arabien. Und damals war ich eben das erste Mal in Jida, in Saudi-Arabien. Und das war eine coole Reise. Unsere Professorin hat ganz viele interessante Termine arrangiert, wir haben Organisationen und Institutionen besucht, viele interessante Leute getroffen. Und das kam mir natürlich dann alles zugute, als ich mich auf diese Stelle beworben hab. Weil Saudi-Arabien ist ein Land, in das man typischerweise nicht reisen kann als Tourist, weil keine Touristen-Visa vergeben werden. Du kannst dir jetzt nicht überlegen, dass du nach Saudi-Arabien reisen möchtest, das würde nicht klappen. Du würdest da nicht reinkommen. Weil Saudi-Arabien keine Touristen-Visa vergeben, weil das so ist. Weil du nichts versuchen hast. Genau. Also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel Muslim wärst, könntest du natürlich sagen, du möchtest gerne die Pilgerreise nach Mecca machen. Das würdest du dann aber typischerweise wahrscheinlich über ein Pilgerreisen-Reisebüro hier in Berlin machen, die das dann für dich organisieren und für dich auch das Visum beantragen würden. Wenn du jetzt ein wichtiger Businessman bist, ein Deutscher, hast du auch die Chance, irgendwie ein Visum zu bekommen, aber dann müsstest du irgendwie schon einen saudischen Partner haben, der für dich bürgt oder den plausibel macht, warum du da jetzt hinreisen sollst. Oder wenn du Familie hast, kannst du die da besuchen. Aber das war's eigentlich auch schon. Es gibt keine Transit-Visa und es gibt keine Touristen-Visa. Ja, Mensch, lernst du intern noch was Neues? Na, das war auch der Grund, warum ich eben damals diese Studienreise von der Uni mitmachen wollte. Weil ich eben wusste, das ist ein Land, in das man nicht wie Ägypten oder Marokko einfach mal eben im Urlaub hinfahren kann, wenn man sich das mal anschauen möchte vor Ort. Da hab ich gesagt, nee, da schlag ich auf jeden Fall zu. Da will ich jetzt hin. Und deswegen war mir klar, als ich mich auf die Stelle beworben habe, in Jeddah in Saudi-Arabien als Kulturmanagerin, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht so viele andere Mitbewerberinnen und Mitbewerber gibt, die schon sagen können, ich kenne die Stadt, um die es geht. Ich war da schon mal. Ich bin da schon mal hingereist. Ich kenne mich da aus. Ich weiß, worauf ich mich einlasse, wenn ich sage, ich bin bereit da ein, zwei oder drei Jahre zu leben.
Und das hast du jetzt auch gemacht?
Das habe ich jetzt auch gemacht. Zwei Jahre war ich jetzt da.
Und nur dort?
Nur dort. Ich habe in Jeddah gelebt, rund um Jura.
Aber du warst auch mal around?
Ich bin auch rumgereist. Ich bin auch in vielen verschiedenen anderen Landesteilen gewesen auf Reisen. Das hat sich zum Glück ergeben, aber ich habe in Jeddah gelebt.
Jeddah war meine Homebase. also Jeddah ist Westküste. Das ist das Rotes Meer.
Das Rote Meer, genau.
Genau. Also gegenüber Vom Sudan. Vom Sudan. Also schon recht weit unten und direkt um die Ecke von Mekka.
Genau. Ungefähr anderthalb Autostunden von Mekka entfernt.
musstest du denn da tun? Also was muss man sich jetzt unter Kulturmanagement sozusagen vorstellen?
Also ich, das Programm Kulturmanager in der arabischen Welt, das macht die Robert-Bosch-Stiftung schon seit vielen Jahren und die schicken junge Leute in verschiedene arabische Länder, um dort sozusagen den interkulturellen Kulturaustausch und Dialog zu befördern, könnte man sagen. Und in den anderen arabischen Ländern, wie zum Beispiel Ägypten, sind die Kulturmanager der Robert-Bosch-Stiftung typischerweise an das Goethe-Institut angegliedert. Also meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen in Ägypten zum Beispiel, die haben in Kairo am Goethe-Institut gearbeitet und weil es aber in Saudi-Arabien kein Goethe-Institut gibt, ist Saudi-Arabien so ein Spezialfall und fällt heraus aus dem Programm Kulturmanager in der arabischen Welt. Da ist nämlich die Position als Kulturmanagerin an das Deutsche Generalkonsulat angegliedert. Das heißt, ich hatte ein Büro am Deutschen Generalkonsulat in Jida. Und ich habe da im wesentlichen Kulturveranstaltungen organisiert und gemanagt. Also ich habe zum Beispiel Ausstellungen gemacht, Konzerte, Workshops, Vorträge. Es ging immer irgendwie um den Austausch zwischen Deutschland und Saudi-Arabien. Also immer irgendein Thema, was für beide Länder irgendwie interessant oder relevant ist. Typischerweise habe ich dann jemanden aus Deutschland eingeladen, eine Künstlerin, irgendwelche Experten, die dann zum Beispiel einen Workshop geben in Saudi-Arabien, sodass im Endeffekt beide Seiten was davon haben. Also die Person, die ich aus Deutschland eingeladen habe, fährt nach Hause und hatte die Gelegenheit, sich Saudi-Arabien mal vor Ort anzugucken und sich fachlich auch mit Leuten auszutauschen, die eben aus einer ganz anderen Region kommen. Und die Leute vor Ort, für die ich das organisiert habe, für die ist es natürlich auch interessant, wenn jemand von außen zu Besuch kommt und jetzt die deutsche Perspektive darstellt und da eben so ein Austausch stattfindet. Und das ist dann, je nach Thema geht es da wie gesagt um Musik oder um Kunst oder um ganz andere Themen. Also wird immer so das verbindende Element gesucht sozusagen.
Vielleicht wollen wir mal so einen kleinen Schritt nochmal zurückgehen und so diese ganze Nationenstruktur nochmal verstehen. Also gut, Arabien hast du ja schon gesagt, ging von dieser Halbinsel aus sozusagen als Begriff, aber diese ganzen Staaten, wie sie sich heute abbilden, sind ja so alt jetzt in dem Sinne noch nicht.
Nee, die sind sogar ziemlich jung. Also der Staat Saudi-Arabien, so wie er heute besteht, ist 1932 gegründet worden. Es gab auch Vorläuferstaaten, das ist eigentlich kompliziert. Das heutige Staatsgebiet und der heutige Staat und die heutige Herrscherfamilie ist sozusagen 1932 das begründet worden. Saudi-Arabien war niemals kolonisiert in dem Sinne und das gilt auch für die anderen Länder auf der arabischen Halbinsel. Die hatten in den verschiedenen weltpolitischen Auseinandersetzungen der vergangenen Jahrhunderte, waren die auch häufig mit irgendwem alliiert, also zum Beispiel mit den Briten. Lawrence of Arabia zum Beispiel kennen ja viele, der war in Saudi-Arabien unterwegs. Aber in dem Sinne waren sie niemals kolonisiert. Und Saudi-Arabien, das Land an sich, das sind Stämme gewesen, Stämmesgebiete, wie man das ja zum Beispiel auch aus Nordafrika kennt. Und diese Stämme gibt es im Prinzip heute auch noch, nur dass es heute ein modernes Land ist. Und die sind von dem Staatsbegründer, dem König Abd al-Sis al-Saud, auf den die Herrscherfamilie zurückgeht und nachdem auch das Land benannt ist, Saudi-Arabien, also das Arabien der Familie al-Saud, genau. Der Staatsgründer Abd al-Sis al-Saud hat sozusagen die Stämme vereinigt und nach und nach das Gebiet erobert, was heutzutage innerhalb der Staatsgrenzen von Saudi-Arabien liegt. Und das führt aber dazu, dass die verschiedenen Regionen und Provinzen tatsächlich auch extrem unterschiedlich sind. Also das stellt man sich vielleicht gar nicht so vor, wenn man an Saudi-Arabien denkt, dann stellt man sich so ein Land vor, das ist es ja auch, es ist ja auch ein Staat, aber die verschiedenen Provinzen sind sehr, sehr unterschiedlich und empfinden sich auch teilweise als sehr unterschiedlich vom Gesamtgebilde des Gesamtstaates. Das liegt eben daran, dass bei der Staatsgründung dieses Gebiet erobert und zusammengefasst wurde zu einem Gebiet.
Das ist ja auch nicht klein. Wenn man sich das mal so geologisch anschaut, ist der Westen eigentlich weitgehend Wüste. Und im Osten an einem Roten Meer geht es dann schon sehr viel bergiger zur Sache, sodass eigentlich auch eigentlich alle großen Städte Saudi-Arabiens sich am Roten Meer befinden.
Im Osten ist die Wüste und im Westen ist das Rote Meer.
Oh, richtig. Ich...
Nie ohne Seife waschen.
Ich behaupte das Gegenteil.
Im Endeffekt ist das alles Wüste. Der einzige Unterschied, dass es im Westen eine Stein- und Geröllwüste ist. Aber es wird zwischendurch auch mal ein bisschen bergig.
Was ich bloß jetzt so absurd finde, ist, dass ausgerechnet die Hauptstadt Riyadh...
Mitten in der Wüste liegt.
Ja, in der Sandwüste.
Und was soll das? Also, ist da irgendwas toll? Gibt es da irgendwie...
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, das ist einfach historisch gewachsen sozusagen. Das ist von... Geh mal ein Stück nach... Aldiria, siehst du das da? Genau, Aldiria im Nordwesten der Hauptstadt Riyadh. Das ist eine kleine Siedlung gewesen und von da aus hat die Expansion angefangen. Sozusagen der Ursprung der Staatsgründung.
Verstehe, da wollten sie halt nie weg.
Genau, da hat er geboren, da ist er geboren und von da aus hat er angefangen, das Land zu erobern. Und deswegen ist Riyadh heute die Hauptstadt. Aber ansonsten finde ich nicht, dass es irgendwas besonders Tolles an Riyadh gibt. Also selbst viele Saudis selber sind jetzt nicht von heißer Liebe für ihre Hauptstadt entbrannt, ehrlich gesagt. Und Jeddah, wo ich gelebt habe, ist ja die zweitgrößte Stadt eben auf der anderen Seite des Landes im Westen am Roten Meer. Und die meisten Saudis empfinden Jeddah auch als die interessantere Stadt, also die Hauptstadt der Herzen eigentlich. Ja, es gibt auch ein ganz lustige Parallele. Die Leute, die in Jeddah leben, sind auch nochmal ganz anders als im Rest des Landes. Das liegt unter anderem daran, dass es eben am Roten Meer ist, dass das eine Handelsstadt schon immer war, dass es das Einfallstor nach Mecca ist, dass jeder, der nach Mecca pilgert, in Jeddah im Prinzip ankommt mit dem Schiff oder mit dem Flugzeug. Und das ist auch heute noch so. Mecca hat keinen eigenen Flughafen. Das heißt, in der Pilgerzeit kommt da alle zwei Minuten ein Charterflugzeug mit Pilgern runter und die werden alle durch Jeddah geschleust. Und Mecca war ja zum Beispiel auch schon ein Pilgerort, bevor der Islam überhaupt auf die Bildfläche getreten ist. Damals sind in Mecca einfach andere Gottheiten angebetet worden. Jeddah war schon immer ein bisschen kosmopolitischer, war schon immer eine Handelsstadt, bisschen offener, liberaler, so ein ethnischer Mix aus verschiedensten Leuten, die da sich angesiedelt haben. Und deswegen ist es da sozusagen auch die Kulturhauptstadt. Und die Jeddawis, so heißen die Leute, die in Jeddah leben, die bilden sich auch ziemlich viel darauf ein, dass sie anders sind als der Rest des Landes. Und da gibt es einen arabischen Spruch, der heißt Jeddareer. Das heißt, Jeddah ist halt anders. Und das ist so ein bisschen, empfinde ich immer, als ziemlich direkte Analogie zu Berlin-Amerbar-Sexy. Also, sie bilden sich fast darauf ein, dass sie ein bisschen cooler sind als alle anderen.
Und das stimmt auch?
Das stimmt auf jeden Fall. Also wie gesagt, das werden ja viele Saudis selber sagen, die in Zweifelsfalle lieber zu einer Geschäftsreise nach Jeddah fahren als nach Riyadh. Oder viele Saudis, die in Jeddah leben, werden quengeln und sich beschweren, wenn sie nach Riyadh müssen, weil in Riyadh ja nichts ist. Riyadh ist langweilig und noch konservativer als der Rest des Landes. Blöd und staubig und anstrengend und der Verkehr und blablabla und Jeddah ist einfach ganz anders.
So, aber jetzt müssen wir ja mal ein bisschen auf diesen Kulturkosmos da, der sich jetzt konkret entfaltet hat, zu sprechen kommen. Also das ist ja schon angedeutet, es war halt anders als in Ägypten. Wie muss man sich dieses Land vorstellen? Also mich hat das ja schon ein bisschen überrascht, ich hab da auch ehrlich gesagt nie darüber nachgedacht, dass sozusagen Touristen, dass dieses Konzept eigentlich erst mal so gar nicht existiert. Das ist erstaunlich, also ich meine, es würden ja sicherlich welche hinfahren wollen.
Du, man kann wundervoll tauchen, am Roten Meer zum Beispiel in der Nähe von Jeddah. Viele von meinen Freunden haben ganz viel getaucht. Das ist als Tauchgebiet fast unerschlossen. Die Leute tauchen ja im gleichen Meer auf der anderen Seite, in Ägypten zum Beispiel, und bezahlen da irgendwie Geld. In Saudi-Arabien ist das halt unerschlossenes Tauchgebiet. Du hast da wunderschöne Korallenriffe. Du hast historische Städte, die spannend sind. Im Norden des Landes ist Madani Zale. Das ist so eine alte Nabatea-Nekropole, die im Prinzip von der gleichen Kultur erbaut ist, die auch Petra in Jordanien gebaut hat, was sicher viele Leute kennen. Das ist total toll, das ist ja super spannend. Also egal, ob du jetzt eine Bildungsreise machst oder einen Strandurlaub machen möchtest oder so, Saudi-Arabien bietet sich meiner Meinung nach als Tourismusland theoretisch an. Also ich hab viel am Strand gelegen auch in den zwei Jahren, in denen ich da gelebt habe und fand das auch sehr schön und vermisse das jetzt auch sehr.
Okay, das kann ich verstehen. Gut, aber es gibt da jetzt nicht so Touristen-Hotels oder sowas in größerem Maße, aber...
Es gibt riesige Hotels und Luxushotels und so, aber die sind halt jetzt nicht für westlichen Strand- und Hauchtourismus ausgerichtet, sondern entweder für Geschäftsreisende oder für Pilgerreisende oder für Besucher aus anderen arabischen Ländern, die vielleicht sagen, okay, sie wollen die Pilgerfahrt machen und bei der Gelegenheit nochmal eine Woche in Jeddah dranhängen und ein bisschen in Jeddah abhängen.
Jetzt assoziiert man ja vor allem immer Religion mit Saudi-Arabien. Das ist sicherlich nicht ganz so unrecht. Das spielt dann eine extreme Rolle. Es gibt halt dort diese starke Form des sunnitischen Islams, den Wahhabitismus. Man weiß ja immer nicht so genau, bei den Ismen, wo man da noch irgendwie was anhängen soll. Wie schlägt sich das näher? Ist das da ein Thema? Kriegst du das sowieso sofort mit? Bestimmt das alles oder ist es nebenbei?
Nein, es ist bestimmt alles. Du kannst es nicht mitkriegen. Das geht damit los. Eine der auffälligsten Sachen im Alltag sind die Gebetszeiten. Fünfmal am Tag wird gebetet. Das ist zwar in allen anderen arabischen und islamisch geprägten Ländern auch so, aber da ist das wesentlich dezenter. Wenn du in Ägypten bist, ist Gebetszeit, dann hörst du den Mulsin rufen und registrierst das am Rande deiner Aufmerksamkeit. Du denkst dir, okay, Gebetszeit und vielleicht macht dein Taxifahrer aus Piyetet das Radio aus oder irgendwie in dem kleinen Kiosk macht einer so ein bisschen die Musik aus. Aber ansonsten, und vielleicht gehen auch ein paar Leute in die Moschee. Oder du siehst Leute am Straßenrand, die zusammen beten. Aber es ist nicht so krass wie in Saudi-Arabien. In Saudi-Arabien ist nämlich so, dass zur Gebetszeit alles zugemacht wird. Alle Geschäfte machen zu, alle Restaurants. Und dann für eine halbe Stunde wird alles runtergefahren. Und das musst du halt einfach wissen. Das musst du einplanen, weil dein Alltag ist einfach mal screwed, wenn du das nicht weißt. Das ist einmal vor Sonnenaufgang, einmal mittags, einmal am Nachmittag, einmal zum Sonnenuntergang und dann noch einmal in der Nacht. Also fünfmal. Also gerade man hat das Gefühl, dass sich das gerade am Nachmittag, so zur Feierabendzeit, dass sich da besonders häufen die Gebete, was halt besonders blöd ist, weil gerade wenn du irgendwie auf dem Weg nach der Arbeit noch irgendwas auf dem Weg nach Hause erledigen oder einkaufen willst, musst du halt echt immer gucken, ist gerade Gebetszeit oder nicht, weil es halt blöd ist, wenn du eine halbe Stunde vom Supermarkt stehst und darauf wartest, dass er wieder aufmacht.
Das heißt, da machen komplette Supermärkte mal eben für eine halbe Stunde zu und alle müssen raus? Unterschiedlich.
Je nachdem, wie groß der Laden ist und wie cool die damit sind, wie die das handeln. Also kleinere Läden würden tatsächlich alle Leute rausschmeißen, das Licht ausmachen und die Tür abschließen und die Rollos runterlassen. Große Supermärkte schließen zu, aber wenn du einmal drin bist, kannst du auch drin bleiben. Also du kannst es auch so timen, dass du sagst, du gehst noch rein, kurz bevor die Gebetszeit anfängt. Hast dann eine halbe Stunde, um alle Dinge zu shoppen, die du kaufen möchtest. Aber du kannst halt auch nicht an der Kasse bezahlen und nicht raus, bevor die Gebetszeit nicht wieder zu Ende ist. Das heißt, das musst du auch einpreisen. Du bist dann halt die halbe Stunde auch in dem Laden gefangen.
Okay, aber das ist so der Sweet Spot. So große Einkäufe und da hat man dann wahrscheinlich auch die Ruhe, weil dann in Ansicht nicht so viel los ist.
Ja, abgesehen von allen anderen Leuten, die das auch so machen. Aber du hast halt nicht die Flexibilität, zu kommen und zu gehen. Du musst es immer irgendwie einpreisen.
Und nicht alle anderen beten?
Das hängt davon ab, wie religiös du bist. Es gibt bestimmt auch viele, die beten. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass jede einzelne Person betet. Weil die individuelle Religiosität unterschiedlich stark ausgeprägt ist. Es sind auch nicht alle Muslime. Viele von den Gastarbeitern sind auch Christen zum Beispiel. Aber das ist einfach was, das musst du wissen. Das kann deinen Alltag ganz schön, das bestimmt deinen Alltag ganz stark. Deswegen hat jeder auf seinem Smartphone eine Prayer Time App. Da gibt es viele verschiedene von. Die Uhrzeiten für die Gebetzeit, die verschieben sich ja auch immer, weil die ja vom Sonnenstand, blablabla, abhängig sind. Das heißt, du kannst ja auch nicht merken, es ist immer um vier oder es ist immer um halb eins, sondern es verrutscht auch immer noch ein bisschen. So. Deswegen sagt dir deine Uhr immer, welcher Tag ist und wo du gerade bist. Das unterscheidet sich auch örtlich. Vor zwei, drei Monaten war ich noch auf einer Geschäftsreise in Riyadh, auf der anderen Seite des Landes und dann sind die Gebetszeiten einfach alle in der Stunde früher. Und weil ich so ein Aluhutbetriebssystem habe, was meine Geolocation nicht erfasst, hatte ich dann immer die falsche Gebetszeit. Weil mein Smartphone dachte, ich wäre immer noch in Jidda und alle haben gesagt, jetzt machen wir zu, weil jetzt wird gebetet und ich habe gesagt, hey, wieso ihr betet doch erst in der Stunde?
Aber das brauchst du auf jeden Fall.
Um deinen Alltag zu sortieren. Und es gibt natürlich auch viele Leute, die dann beten. Also selbst wenn du irgendwo... Na ja, der Muezzin ruft ja trotzdem. Also du wirst es nicht verpassen, weil alle Muezzine rufen alle gleichzeitig. Du hörst es immer, überall, egal wo du bist.
Der Punkt ist nur, die Frage ist, ob du es vorher weißt.
Ob du es vorher weißt und ob du dich darauf einstellen kannst. Ob du irgendwie deine Fahrten durch die Stadt oder deine Termine irgendwie so sortierst, dass es dann irgendwie passt, wenn du dich mit Leuten abends zum Essen triffst, dass du sagst, okay, lass uns am Ende der ersten Gebetszeit ins Restaurant gehen, dann können wir bestellen und essen und bezahlen am Ende von der zweiten Gebetszeit oder so. Siehst du, da gibt es viele verschiedene. Diverse. Der zeigt ja halt die Uhrzeit an. Je nachdem, wo du gerade bist, wann die Gebetszeiten sind. Und meistens ist auch noch ein Kompass dabei, damit du im Zweifelsfalle auch noch, egal wo du bist, mitmitteln kannst, in welche Richtung Mecca ist, damit du auch in die richtige Richtung betest.
Schöne Islamische App, 2 Millionen Anwender weltweit. Gleich mit Koran, Versen und so.
Du kannst auch einstellen, wie die dich erinnern soll, wie die rufen soll. Also Beine hat immer nur so ein kleines Pling gemacht. Das war das gleiche Geräusch, wie wenn ich SMS oder E-Mails bekommen habe. Du kannst auch einstellen, dass dann der Mulzin dich ruft. Der Mulzin auf deinem Handy ruft und sagt, es ist Zeit. Jetzt kannst du dich einstellen. Also das kannst du nicht übersehen.
Jetzt ist das aber mit Mekka da wahrscheinlich nochmal extra krass, oder? Ich meine, nach Mekka pilgern doch eigentlich permanent am laufenden Meter welche, oder? Around the year, immer ist da was los.
Das ist richtig. Also es gibt den Pilgermonat, den Hajmonat, der sich mehr oder weniger direkt an Ramadan anschließt. Der Heiligemonat sozusagen, wo du quasi doppelte Karma-Punkte bekommst, wo dann besonders hohes Aufkommen ist. Da sind auch nochmal die Rituale, die du machst. Im Hajmonat, im Pilgermonat sind auch nochmal spezielle, die du machst. Das ist diese Haj, eine der fünf Säulen des Islam. Dass man eben einmal im Leben nach Möglichkeit, wenn man kann, die Haj, die Pilgerreise gemacht haben soll nach Mekka.
Und dann konzentriert sich das auch noch auf einen bestimmten Monat, oder was?
Genau, und innerhalb dieses Monats auch noch auf bestimmte Tage. Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum du da immer diese Verstopfungen hast und auch immer wieder diese Massenpaniken oder Unfälle hast, wie es zum Beispiel letztes Jahr der Fall war. Weil da einfach eine unvorstellbar große Menge an Menschen auf extrem kleinem Raum die gleichen Dinge tut und die gleichen Rituale vollzieht. Weil sich das halt zeitlich und räumlich überhaupt nicht entzehrt. Also die versuchen schon, das perfekt durchzuorganisieren und logistisch das alles perfekt zu machen. Aber wenn du einfach mal, weiß ich nicht, zwei, drei, vier Millionen Menschen in einer kleinen Stadt, in einer kleinen Gasse hast und die alle gleichzeitig damit beschäftigt sind, symbolisch den Teufel zu steinigen oder um die Kabe herumzuziehen siebenmal oder so, dann ist das einfach logistisch eine ganz schöne Herausforderung. Das ist sozusagen, das ist der Hatschmonat und die große, die große Pilger. Ja du, das sind ja, das wiederum, das ist das islamische Monatjahr. Die sind ja auch in einer ganz anderen Zeitrechnung. Die sind in einem anderen Jahr, die haben andere Monate. Die Monate sind anders geschnitten als unsere. Der Monat heißt Hatsch. So wie der Monat davor Ramadan heißt. Aber auch der wandert im Jahr, weil es eben nach dem Monatjahr heißt. Also im Moment sind wir so, dass Ramadan immer ungefähr im Juni ist und Hatsch dann ungefähr im September so. August, September. Im Sommer. Im Sommer wird erst gefastet und dann gepilgert. Und wenn gerade nicht Hatschmonat ist, dann kann man den größten Teil des restlichen Jahres die kleine Pilgerreise machen, die heißt nicht Hatsch, sondern Umrah. Und da macht man dann etwas andere Rituale als bei der Hatsch, aber das zählt halt wie die kleine Pilgerreise. Und auch dafür gibt es gute Kamerapunkte sozusagen. Und auch das machen viele Leute die ganze Zeit. Das machen viele Leute, wenn sie zufällig sowieso vorbeikommen oder weil sie sagen, jetzt wäre mal eine gute Gelegenheit, jetzt habe ich gerade Zeit. Also weil dieser Wunsch, einmal im Leben in Mekka gewesen zu sein, glaube ich schon bei den allermeisten Muslimen tatsächlich vorhanden ist. Na, das geht auf den Propheten Mohammed zurück, der aus Mekka fliehen musste nach Medina und dann zurückgekehrt ist nach Mekka. Also das hat mit der ganzen Ursprungs- und Entstehungsgeschichte des Islam zu tun. Und auch die verschiedenen Rituale, die sie da machen. Dann pilgern sie zum Berg Arafat und dann sitzen sie auf dem Berg Arafat, wo Gott mit Mohammed gesprochen haben soll. Also das sind alles Rituale, die mit der Ursprungsgeschichte des Islam zu tun haben, die da vollzogen werden. Und das ist schon super interessant und man muss das einfach wissen, dass auch diese Pilgerreise eine super wichtige Rolle spielt, auch wirtschaftlich, muss man ja einfach mal überlegen. Es gibt sozusagen keinen Tourismus jetzt im westlichen Sinne, haben wir darüber geredet. Aber du hast halt trotzdem super viele Leute aus der ganzen Welt, die ständig dahin reisen, die in Hotels wohnen, die in Restaurants gehen, die von A nach B gekarrt werden müssen, die mit dem Bus vom Flughafen nach Mecca fahren, die dann vielleicht bei der Gelegenheit noch was anderes anschauen. Das ist ein riesiger Wirtschaftsfaktor. Und Mecca selbst wird auch seit Jahren immer krasser ausgebaut. Also, die bauen da ein riesiges Luxushotel neben dem anderen, alle so rund um den Heiligen Bezirk, um die Kaaba, rum um die Heilige Moschee. Das ist eine einzige riesige Construction-Zeit schon seit Jahren. Es gibt auch viele Saudis, die das extrem uncool finden und das auch sehr stark kritisieren, dass sie sagen, der ursprüngliche Charakter der Stadt geht immer mehr verloren und es wird immer mehr zu so einem Pilger Disneyland sozusagen. Du siehst da diese riesigen Türme, dann gibt es diesen absurd riesigen Clock Tower, dieser riesige Urenturm, der so ein bisschen an Big Ben erinnert, aber im islamischen Stil, den du auch wirklich aus zwei Kilometer Entfernung siehst, wenn du auf der Autobahn an Mecca vorbeifährst, kannst du trotzdem gucken, wie spät es gerade ist in Mecca. Das ist schon super gigantomanisch. Das ist total heftig. Und die heilige Moschee, die um die Kammer rumgebaut ist, ist zwar auch immer und immer und immer wieder erweitert und vergrößert worden. Und es ist inzwischen auch riesengroß, aber wirkt halt wirklich zwergenhaft im Verhältnis zu den riesigen gigantomanischen Luxushotels, die drumherum sind. Und die Gegend da in Mecca ist ja so ein bisschen hügelig auch. Und an diesen Hügeln sind viele ursprüngliche Viertel sozusagen, wo die Menschen gelebt haben. Aber die werden da teilweise auch zwangsenteignet weggesiedelt. Die Hügel werden gesprengt und da wird ein neues riesiges Hotel hingebaut. Die Pilgerreisenden, die auf dem Weg sind nach Mecca, die erkennt man daran, dass sie schon ihre typische Pilgerkleidung tragen. Bei den Männern sind das so weiße Handtücher. Typischerweise haben die so eins um die Hüfte geschlungen und eins um den Oberkörper und tragen dazu Badellatschen, weil das bestimmte Vorschriften sind, die schon mit der Reise nach Mecca zu tun haben. Alle sollen gleich sein, alle sollen das Gleiche tragen. Kleidung, die nicht verarbeitet ist, die gleiche Farbe ist. Man soll keinen Unterschied zwischen Arm und Reich sehen. Ich hatte mal eine Gästin sozusagen für ein Projekt, die ich abgeholt habe in Jeddah am Flughafen, die sich das nicht so richtig erklären konnte, warum der Typ in der ersten Reihe am Anfang noch normale Sachen anhatte und dann später zwei Handtücher umgeschlungen hatte und sie hat dann versucht, das irgendwie sich plausibel zu erklären, meinte, der hat sich bestimmt einfach Kaffee über alle seine Klamotten gekippt und deswegen läuft er jetzt in Handtüchern rum. Und ich hab sie dann aufgeklärt, dass der sich umgezogen hat, weil das eine Pilgerreisenbekleidung ist. Aber wenn du da nicht drauf vorbereitet bist, dann hast du echt Schwierigkeiten, dir das irgendwie plausibel zu machen. Warum da jetzt ein erwachsener Mann nur mit zwei Handtüchern bekleidet und im Koffer durch den Flughafen läuft. Ja, kann man schon sagen. Und es gibt auch wirklich viele saudische, moderne Künstler, die sich sehr kritisch auch damit auseinandersetzen. Einige davon sind auch in der westlichen Welt bekannt. Zum Beispiel Ahmed Mata ist ein relativ bekannter saudischer Künstler, der viele kritische Kunstwerke geschaffen hat, die sich eben mit dieser Disneyland-Verumbauung von Mecca auseinandersetzt und sagt, dass das eigentlich gar nicht mehr so cool ist.
Jetzt hast du ja gesagt, gut, bleiben wir mal dabei. Kritisch auseinandersetzen ist ja jetzt nicht unbedingt so, wofür Saudi-Arabien besonders bekannt ist. Jetzt ist das alles irgendwie das Arabien des Saud und auch so den Eindruck, dass sich da eigentlich relativ viel um die Herrscher dreht und sonst eigentlich nicht so viel. Wie ist so, welche Rolle, also wie muss man sich quasi das politische System vorstellen und verdient es diesen Namen überhaupt?
Okay, also das politische System kannst du dir so vorstellen, du fährst in einer beliebigen Stadt in Saudi-Arabien, dabei nehmen wir mal Jida die Straße runter und wenn du einen Kilometer gefahren bist, hast du ungefähr 37 Portraits des Königs gesehen am Straßenrand oder an irgendeiner Mall dran oder an einer Schule oder an einem beliebigen anderen Bürogebäude. Das Portrait des Königs ist überall, das ist auf den Geldscheinen, das ist an jeder Wand.
Des aktuellen Königs oder des Gründner Königs?
Sowohl auch als auch, aber meistens ist es der aktuelle König. Also der jetzt gerade ausgetauscht wurde? Nach einem Jahr. Der vorhergehende ist gestorben und sein Halbbruder ist daraufhin König geworden. Ich muss sagen, ich hab das ja vor Ort direkt erlebt. Ich war auch echt überrascht. Der alte König ist gestorben. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, am nächsten Tag waren alle Portraits ausgetauscht. Und wir reden hier nicht nur von so DIN A4, sondern wir reden hier von riesigen Dingern, die an riesigen Häuserwänden dran sind. Wo ich dann echt dachte, die müsste er ja schon in der Schublade gehabt haben. Ich mein, gut, der alte König, der dann gestorben ist, der lag zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo er gestorben ist, auch schon ein, zwei Wochen im Koma. Also das war schon abzusehen. Das war jetzt nicht so mega überraschend, dass er gestorben ist.
Es war auch klar, wer der Nachfolger wird.
Es war klar, wer der Nachfolger ist. Die Thronfolge ist immer geregelt. Es gibt immer einen designierten Thronfolger. Und der vorhergehende König, kenn ich Abdullah, der eben 2015 im Frühjahr gestorben ist, der hat eingeführt, dass es auch noch einen stellvertretenden Thronfolger gibt, was sehr sinnvoll ist, weil dadurch natürlich die Thronfolge nicht nur auf den unmittelbaren Nachrückerplatz, sondern auch schon auf den zweiten Nachrückerplatz geklärt ist und ein bisschen Konfliktpotenzial rausgenommen wird, aber auch nicht alles. Der Punkt, warum das sinnvoll war, das so einzurichten, ist der, dass der Staatsgründer, von dem ich vorhin schon kurz gesprochen habe, Abdülaziz al-Saud, der dieses ganze Staatsgebiet erobert und geeint hat, hatte sehr, sehr viele Söhne, ich glaube 46 oder so. Pfleißiger Mensch. Der hat seine Zeit gut genutzt. Und das sind nur die Söhne. Also irgendwie um den Dreh ungefähr 46 Söhne. Und die Thronfolge in Saudi-Arabien hat in den letzten Jahrzehnten nicht so funktioniert, dass immer der älteste Sohn des ältesten Sohnes des ältesten Sohnes drankommt, sondern als der Gründer Abdülaziz al-Saud gestorben ist, ist sein ältester Sohn ans Ruder gekommen. Aber danach sind sozusagen alle Söhne von Abdülaziz der Reihe nach drankommen, sozusagen in einer Generation. Es waren immer die Halbbrüder, die der Reihe nach drangekommen sind, dem Alter nach. Also immer wenn einer stirbt, kommt der nächste jüngere Halbbruder.
Weil das auch so von vornherein vorgesehen war?
Das haben die so festgelegt. Darauf haben die sich geeinigt. Weil es dann sehr kompliziert wird und sehr weit verzweigt wird, weil wenn ein Sohn und dann viele Söhne von vielen Frauen und very complicated. Also es war einfacher zu sagen, wir gehen immer die...
Ja, also bleiben sie dann auch alle, wird nicht so viele Erneuerungen mit sich gebracht.
Die haben natürlich auch alle jeweils sehr große weitere Familien gegründet und diese Herrscherfamilie ist extrem groß und extrem weit verzweigt. Manchmal sagt man, Saudi-Arabien ist das Land der 1000 Prinzen und das ist auch nicht so untertrieben.
Aber Töchter hat er auch gehabt, oder?
Ja, viele Töchter, alle diese Prinzen haben auch Töchter, aber manche von denen sind auch relevant und haben Einflüsse, aber im Wesentlichen geht es immer um die Söhne. Die Söhne kommen auf den Thron, die Töchter nicht. Und dann hast du halt diese Halbbrüder, die der Reihe nach drankommen. Immer wenn einer stirbt, kommen dann die jüngere dran, es sei denn einer sagt, ich setze aus, oder ist unsuitable, also das gab es auch schon, dass einer drangekommen ist, wo der Familienrat dann fand, der hat sich aber nicht besonders gut geschlagen als Herrscher, der dann dazu überredet wird, abzudanken und an den Nächsten Jüngeren abzugeben, kam auch schon vor. So, und jetzt ist es aber natürlich so, dass die ja dann alle schon sehr alt waren. Die waren alle Ende ihrer 80er und dem vorhergehenden König, König Abdullah, der bis 2015 geherrscht hat, war es geschehen, dass viele seiner Thronfolger, die nachrücken sollten, immer so im Halbjahresabstand gestorben sind. König Abdullah ist glaube ich 91 oder 92 geworden, als er gestorben ist. Und seine nächstjüngeren Halbbrüder, die waren dann halt 89 und 88 und 87 und haben ihn nicht überlebt. Das heißt, es war klar, der und der ist der Thronfolger, ist der Nachrücker und der ist dann, weiß nicht, am Herzinfarkt gestorben. Und dann kam der nächste Jüngere dran und der ist auch ein halbes Jahr später gestorben. Und deswegen hat König Abdullah gesagt, okay, da wir jetzt alle in einem Alter sind, wo das ganz schnell gehen kann, müssen wir auch noch den zweiten Nachrücker-Platz schon festlegen, den stellvertretenden Thronfolger. Das hat er auch gemacht. Dann ist bei dem Wechsel, als Abdullah gestorben ist und sein nächstes jüngere Halbbruder König Salman, der jetzt herrscht, als der drangekommen ist, da ist tatsächlich auch noch einer ausgetauscht worden, der eigentlich dran gewesen wäre, den sie aber auch überredet haben abzudanken und nachzurücken. Und bei der jetzigen Thronfolge ist das Spannende, dass der jetzige Anwärter sozusagen, der Thronfolger und der stellvertretende Thronfolger, das sind die ersten aus der nächsten Generation. Also, die Heilbrüder, die ganzen Söhne des Staatsgründers sind in gewisser Hinsicht aufgebraucht, oder die sind keine mehr übrig.
Als nächstes kommt ein Enkel dran.
Genau, als nächstes kommt ein Enkel dran. Und der Thronfolger, der jetzt Innenminister ist, ist ein Neffe des Herrschers des Königs. Und der stellvertretende Thronfolger ist der Sohn des Königs. Und das ist deswegen pikant, weil ok, jetzt steigen wir ein bisschen tief ein und Thronfolge ist ein Thema, das ich gerne mag. Also bremst mich, wenn es zu ausführlich wird, weil darüber kann ich sehr lange reden. Also das ist deswegen brisant, weil ich habe ja schon gesagt, es gab diese vielen, vielen Halbbrüder, die auch unterschiedliche Fraktionen gebildet haben. Eine der wichtigsten Fraktionen waren die Soudairi 7. Das waren sieben Halbbrüder, die alle die gleiche Mutter hatten, die sozusagen Vollblutbrüder waren, die anderen ja alle Halbbrüder sind. Und die haben in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten eine wichtige politische Einheit gebildet. Und es war häufig so, dass die wichtigsten politischen Posten im Land so aufgeteilt waren, dass es immer ein Gleichgewicht gab zwischen den Soudairi 7 und einer anderen Fraktion. Dass zum Beispiel wenn eine der beiden Fraktionen den König stellt, ist klar, der Innenminister und oder der Außenminister werden von der anderen Fraktion gestellt. Dass es immer wie eine Waage im Gleichgewicht ist. Und die Soudairi 7 waren jetzt eine Weile nicht dran als Könige sozusagen, aber der jetzige König ist wieder einer von denen, ist der Letzte von den Soudairi 7. Und dadurch, dass der stellvertretende Thronfolger sein eigener Sohn ist und wieder jemand aus der Fraktion und er als er die Macht übernommen hat im Prinzip alle Ministerposten, alle Leute, die irgendwie Einfluss hatten, ausgetauscht hat durch seine eigenen Leute oder Leute aus seiner eigenen Familie, aus seinem eigenen Familienzweig, ist quasi diese Balance so ein bisschen aus dem Gleichgewicht geraten. Also dieser eine Zweig der Familie, der Sudeiri, der Sudeiri-Klan sozusagen innerhalb der Königsfamilie hat jetzt alle einflussreichen Positionen. Ist stark überrepräsentiert im Verhältnis dazu, wie es in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten gelaufen und innerhalb der Herrscherfamilie gehandhabt wurde. Das könnte zu Unruhe am Hofe führen in der Tat. Und auch der herrschende König ist schon sehr, sehr alt, das glaube ich auch schon 87 oder 88, glaube ich jetzt. Manche sagen, er ist auch gesundheitlich nicht ganz auf der Höhe, hätte auch schon den einen oder anderen Schlaganfall gehabt. Also er reist noch viel durch die Weltgeschichte und herrscht. Also er ist noch nicht unfähig zu herrschen, aber er ist eben auch schon sehr alt. Und sein Sohn, der Außenminister ist und hauptsächlich für den Krieg im Jemen zum Beispiel verantwortlich ist, der gilt halt als sehr aufbrausend und ehrgeizig und ambitioniert. Und ja, also man kann sich denken, dass da Unruhe am Hof ist, aber es trinkt nicht sehr viel davon nach außen. Die Königfamilie ist sehr darauf bedacht, immer noch als Einheit nach außen zu erscheinen. Und man hört nicht viel davon, was dahinter verschlossenen Türen so vor sich geht. Man wird dann mit den Ergebnissen präsentiert.
Welchen Status hat denn das in dem Land? Also nehmen die das alle so hin, ist halt einfach so oder wie ist das Revolutionspotenzial? Also erst mal überhaupt, ich meine, man kann sich das ja nun wirklich sehr schwer vorstellen.
Eine absolute Monarchie, wo alles auf den König zugeschnitten ist. Und der König alles entscheidet.
Genau, so. Also ich meine, ein bisschen Kaiser und so weiter hatten wir auch. Das war, glaube ich, dann im Detail schon noch mal ein bisschen anders aufgestellt. Hier ist es halt noch mal mega extrem und vor allem ist es halt irgendwie 2016 und es ist halt so.
Ja, es wirkt tatsächlich auf den ersten Blick sehr feudal und es ist eine absolute Monarchie, kann man nicht anders sagen. Alles geht auf den König zurück. Der König kann alles entscheiden. Es gibt zwar ein Konsultativgremium, also einen Rat, der Gesetze dem König vorschlägt, aber wenn der Rat abstimmt, dann stimmt er darüber ab, ob sie die dem König vorschlagen. Aber der Rat, das Parlament in dem Sinne oder das, was am ehesten einem Parlament entspricht nach saulischem Maß, das macht keine Gesetze. Das schlägt Gesetze vor und der König hat Lust, die umzusetzen oder nicht. Zudem kommt, wir haben ja vorhin schon über Religion gesprochen, dass der König nicht nur sozusagen politisch und auf der Verwaltungsseite dem Staat vorsteht, sondern auch in religiöser Hinsicht. Er trägt auch den Titel Hüter der beiden heiligen Städten, also Saudi-Arabien und die Herrscherfamilie nehmen ja für sich auch in Anspruch, dass sie den wahren ursprünglichen Islam und das Heimatland des Islam bewahren und beschützen für den Rest der muslimischen Gemeinde in der Welt und eben unter anderem diese Pilgerreise immer organisieren und sich diese ganze Logistik aufhalten. Und das ist ein Titel, den sie auch mit Stolz tragen, wo eben auch so ein religiöser Primatanspruch transportiert wird, dass sie den richtigen Islam vertreten und repräsentieren. Und das Revolutionspotenzial schätze ich persönlich als verhältnismäßig gering ein. Tendenz steigend. Also das war eine der Sachen, die ich am interessantesten und am überraschendsten fand, als ich das erste Mal nach Saudi-Arabien gekommen bin 2009, aber auch später, dass die gar nicht alle darauf warten, eine Demokratie nach westlichem Vorbild umzusetzen. Also die finden das interessant und viele drängen auch auf mehr Demokratisierung im Land. Aber extrem erstaunlich viele Leute, mit denen man sich unterhält, finden das eigentlich auch ganz angemessen mit dieser absoluten Monarchie oder generell mit einer Monarchie erstmal so. Die sagen, das ist unsere Herrscherfamilie und die ist an und für sich schon ganz gut und die präsentieren uns auch gut und wir sind damit immer gut gefahren. Die Gesellschaft ist zwar in vielerlei Hinsicht sehr modernisiert, aber es ist auch immer noch eine traditionelle Stämmegesellschaft. Das heißt, diese Tradition und diese Geschichte lebt in gewisser Hinsicht in der Organisationsstruktur der Menschen, wie sie miteinander leben und ihr Leben organisieren und Politik betreiben auch immer noch fort. Und viele Leute sagen, die Monarchie, das ist eigentlich schon richtig. Jetzt mit dem aktuellen Herrscher und gerade auch mit seinem Sohn, würde ich sagen, ist die Zufriedenheit nicht auf ganz so einem hohen Level wie beim verstorbenen König Abdullah, der extrem beliebt war bei seinem Volk, den alle richtig cool fanden und um den auch sehr, sehr intensiv getrauert wurde, als er 2015 gestorben ist. Also die Leute waren wirklich richtig, richtig traurig. Das hat sogar mich auch emotional erfasst. Oh nein, König Abdullah ist tot, er hat so viel für uns getan. König Abdullah galt immer so als Reformmonarch. Der hat sich viel für Frauenrechte eingesetzt, der hat zum Beispiel entschieden, im Alleingang, weil er es kann, weil er der König ist, dass in diesem Konsultativrat, der ihm die Gesetze vorschlägt, dass da eine feste Frauenquote eingesetzt wird, hat er so mal entschieden. Und auch noch verschiedene andere Sachen. Er hat entschieden, dass Frauen das erst mal wählen können sollen, was dann tatsächlich letztes Jahr passiert ist, Ende 2015. Also noch ganz, ganz viele andere Sachen, dass Frauen, dass Arbeitsplätze für Frauen geschaffen werden, dass Frauen auf dem Arbeitsmarkt können, dass Bildung für Frauen ausgebaut wird, dass generell der Bildungssektor extrem ausgebaut wird vor alle Saudis. Der hat ganz, ganz viele Reformen durchgepusht, würde man jetzt nicht denken. Man guckt auf Saudi Arabien und sagt, ihr hättet mal ein paar Reformen nötig, aber wenn man mal reinzoomt in das Land, hat man das Gefühl, wow, da ist aber ganz schön viel passiert innerhalb sehr kurzer Zeit in den letzten Jahren. Das meiste davon geht eben auf den letzten Herrscher zurück. Deswegen, wie gesagt, ist man erst mal überrascht, das Revolutionspotenzial ist erst mal nicht so hoch, weil die Leute eigentlich zufrieden sind. Ich mein, Saudi-Arabien ist ein reiches Land. Die ruhen sich immer noch ein bisschen auf ihrem Ölreichtum aus, obwohl inzwischen man so ein Gefühl dafür bekommt, das Geld wird weniger und das Ende des Goldbrunnens ist jetzt schon langsam zu sehen und jetzt muss man einen Alternativplan her. Das merkt man, dass das jetzt langsam kommt, aber trotzdem ist es immer noch ein reiches Land. Die meisten Leute, die saudischen Staatsbürger, sag ich jetzt mal nicht, die Gastarbeiter, aber die meisten saudischen Staatsbürger haben ein hohes Lebensniveau, kriegen Strom und Gas geschenkt, haben freien Zugang zu Bildung und Gesundheitswesen, beides auf einem ziemlich guten Niveau und kriegen viele Steuergeschenke auch noch, immer zu irgendwelchen Anlässen. Zum Beispiel, wenn der neue König den Thron besteigt, gibt es wieder Steuergeschenke, jeder kriegt ein zusätzliches Monatsgehalt. Der Staatsapparat, der Beamtenapparat ist sehr groß, sehr, sehr viele Leute sind im Beamtenapparat angestellt und verdienen da gut. Die Leute sind insgesamt relativ, sehr unzufrieden. Also natürlich gibt es eine Mittelschicht und auch eine Bildungselite, die liberaler und auch geschlossener sind und die zum Beispiel auch gerne hätten, dass das Land sich eher in Richtung einer konstitutionellen Monarchie entwickelt. Das sind aber nicht so viele und im Moment werden die auch immer noch mit sehr, sehr starken Repressionen bestraft, wenn sie diese Gedanken äußern. Also wenn du auf Twitter schreibst, eigentlich fände ich ja mal eine konstitutionelle Monarchie ganz töfte, dann landest du auch mal schnell im Knast, weil du öffentliche Unruhe angestiftet hast und den König beleidigt hast oder irgendwie so was.
Verstehen Sie keinen Spaß. In gewisser Hinsicht, wenn ich mir das jetzt anhöre, wie extrem die politische und damit ja auch wirtschaftliche Verflechtung mit dieser Königsfamilie ist, ist ja auch im Prinzip eine Änderung dieses Zustands überhaupt nicht vorstellbar.
Es ist vollkommen unklar, was dann kommen sollte.
Wer sollte das übernehmen? Niemand kommt in dieses Netzwerk rein. Das ist halt da und man muss halt jetzt sehen, wie man damit klarkommt. Nichtsdestotrotz dürfte ja nun auch Saudi-Arabien in zunehmendem Maße darunter leiden, in Anführungsstrichen, dass sie jetzt Teil einer globalen Welt werden. Ich meine, den Tourismus haben sich mit Mecca mal als Ausnahme aus dem Vorgehalten. Das ist ja dann auch immer sozusagen dieses was kümmert uns der Rest der Welt? Uns geht es gut, irgendwo kommt Geld her und Waren. Zumal ja dieses Land gar nicht so viel produzieren kann, wie es verbraucht. Das ist ja wahrscheinlich der Importkönig auf diesem Planeten überhaupt. Ja, alles.
Wobei, du würdest stauen, es gibt auch Gegenden, gerade in den Bergen, wo die Dinge anbauen, auf die du nicht gekommen wärst. Also irgendwie die größte Kaviar-Farm der Welt ist in Saudi-Arabien. Die bauen da auch Äpfel an und Rosen in den Bergen. Und die exportieren sie dann allerdings. Was auch total absurd ist. Also gerade zum Beispiel, also so Blumen und Obst, was die anbauen, exportieren sie. Und was selber konsumiert wird im Land, wird alles importiert. Also wenn du durch den Supermarkt läufst, ist alles importiert. Kommt alles vom Wunder her.
Und das ist natürlich auch ein Lifestyle, den muss man irgendwie halten. Ich hab auch schon den Eindruck, dass das Land schon seit Längerem dabei ist, sich zu rüsten für die Zeit danach. So, was du schon angesprochen hast, ist Bildung. Das scheint mir in der gesamten arabischen Halbinsel so ein Thema zu sein. Gibt es da noch andere Trends?
Na ja, auch so einfach generell, so Dienstleistungssektor. Leute, die irgendwie irgendwas mit Software machen, Medien, YouTuber, Filmer, sonst irgendwelche Dinge, die du anbieten kannst, wo es nicht um die Produktion von Rohren geht, sondern irgendwelche anderen Dienstleistungen. Es gibt einen riesigen Bausektor auch in Saudi-Arabien tatsächlich. Liegt in der Hand von ein, zwei, drei Familien, die damals extrem viel Geld gemacht haben. Also es wird viel gebraucht, so. Aber ansonsten wird da nicht viel produziert oder so. Ja, was, wenn man jetzt mal so perspektivisch in die Zukunft guckt, dann, du hast ja schon gesagt, klar, Saudi-Arabien wird jetzt auch Teil einer globalisierten Welt. Teil dieses Bildungsprogramms oder dieser Bildungsförderung ist, dass in den letzten Jahrzehnten sehr, sehr viele Studierende ins Ausland geschickt wurden zum Studieren. Da gab es halt Stipendien, die in großem Maße vergeben wurden an saudische Studierende, beiderlei Geschlechts. Und die sind meistens nach Amerika gegangen, in die USA. Also manche auch nach Deutschland. Tatsächlich sind viele Saudis schon seit den 70ern in Deutschland zum Studium gewesen, meistens Ärzte und Ingenieure. Du triffst dann da teilweise irgendwie ältere Saudis, die perfekt Deutsch sprechen und die erzählen, dass sie in München studiert haben. Aber die allerallermeisten von denen sind doch in die USA gegangen. Und die kommen dann halt nach ein paar Jahren vielleicht wieder zurück nach Saudi-Arabien und bringen dann natürlich alles, was sie da erlebt haben und die kulturellen Eindrücke zurück mit nach Hause. Genauso wie ich ja jetzt auch die kulturellen Eindrücke, die ich abroad gesammelt habe, mit zurück nach Hause bringe. Das kann sich dann natürlich unterschiedlich entfalten. Du hast dann irgendwie junge Leute, die sagen, sie wollen jetzt Künstler sein oder Designer oder YouTuber zum Beispiel. Es gibt eine riesige YouTube-Szene in Saudi-Arabien, die sehr liberal und sehr weltoffen sind und auch sehr kritisch und eigentlich nicht einsehen, warum die Strukturen in Saudi-Arabien noch so verkrustet sind und auch sehr frustriert davon sind und eher so in Richtung von Wandel und Veränderung pushen. Aber es gibt auch welche, die sagen, das war schöner in den USA und es ist auch toll, was die da alles haben. Aber wenn ich das wieder haben möchte, dann fliege ich halt wieder in die USA und mache da Urlaub. Aber hier zu Hause ist das mit den Traditionen schon ganz in Ordnung. Also nicht zwingend ist es so, dass Leute, die im Ausland anderen Eindrücken ausgesetzt werden, diese Zustände dann auch in ihrem Heimatland herbeiführen wollen. Das ist der Fall und es ist nicht zu leugnen. Und das macht auch einen wichtigen Eindruck in dem Land, dass alle diese Leute zurückkommen vom Studium und eben in der westlichen Welt gelebt haben und gesehen haben, die junge Frauen, die in den USA ihren Führerschein gemacht haben und dann doch ziemlich verständnislos sind, warum sie in Saudi-Arabien nicht Auto fahren dürfen zum Beispiel. Oder Leute, die sich daran gewöhnt haben, dass sie jede Woche nach der Uni noch ins Kino gehen und nicht verstehen, warum in Saudi-Arabien Kinos verboten sind zum Beispiel. Es gibt keine Kinos. Es gibt auch keine Theater. Es gibt auch keine Tanz- oder Musikveranstaltungen. Das ist alles verboten. Und wenn du einmal in den USA gelebt hast, oder generell im Westen, und das dann als normalen Lebensstandard empfindest, dann irritiert dich das halt schon. Und da kommt halt schon, würde ich sagen, ein kleines Revolutionspotenzial her. Das größere Revolutionspotenzial, meiner Meinung nach, kommt daher, dass du wie in fast allen anderen arabischen Ländern der Region auf den Kopf gestellte Alterspyramide hast. Also zwei Drittel der Bevölkerung sind unter 30. In Deutschland ist es genau andersrum. Der größte Teil der Gesellschaft ist alt und wird auch insgesamt immer älter.
Aber das ist fast im ganzen Nahen Osten so.
Das ist fast im ganzen Nahen Osten so, genau. Und das ist ein Problem, was fast alle Länder im Nahen Osten haben, dass du eine sehr junge Bevölkerung hast, der du im Prinzip nichts bieten kannst, die quasi in Perspektivlosigkeit aufwächst. Es gibt nicht genug Arbeitsplätze für sie, sie fühlen sich politisch nicht repräsentiert, haben auch nicht das Gefühl, dass sie irgendwie Einfluss nehmen können, weil alle politischen Entscheidungen in der Hand von verschiedenen alten Entscheidungsträgern in vollgrößeren Strukturen sind. Und daraus entsteht so ein Frustpotenzial, das hast du in Algerien gerade genauso krass wie in Tunesien und in Ägypten auch. Und das ist auch in Saudi-Arabien und den anderen Ländern auf der arabischen Halbinsel on the rise sozusagen. Und dadurch, dass die Einnahmen aus der Ölforderung sinken und klar ist, dass das Land nicht weiterhin nicht endlos lange, zeitlich gesehen, die Bevölkerung mit Steuergeschenken und so weiter befriedigt und satt halten kann und glücklich halten kann, genau, ist klar, dass da einfach mehr Potenzial für Unruhe und Unzufriedenheit entsteht. Der Lebensstandard sinkt kontinuierlich in Saudi-Arabien. Du hast immer mehr eine Mittelschicht, die immer weniger verdient. Es ist jetzt schon häufig so, dass das eine Einkommen des Familienfahrts nicht reicht, um die ganze Familie zu ernähren. Was dazu führt, was auch positive Effekte hat, weil das dazu führt, dass klar ist, unabhängig davon, was die Menschen in der Familie, die männlichen Entscheidungsträger in der Familie so davon halten, wenn Frauen arbeiten, es einfach ökonomisch geboten ist, dass auch Frauen arbeiten gehen und dazu zu verdienen. Das heißt, da entsteht so ein ökonomischer Druck, der auch sich positiv auswirkt, weil es ein logischer Reformdruck ist in jeder einzelnen Mikrozelle in der Familie. Dann hast du das Problem, dann sagst du, deine Frau geht auch arbeiten, um dazu zu verdienen, zum gemeinsamen Haushaltseinkommen. Wie kommt sie denn zur Arbeit? Es gibt ja keinen öffentlichen Nahverkehr. Und sie darf ja nicht Auto fahren. Das heißt, du musst einen Fahrer bezahlen, dass sie zur Arbeit kommen kann.
Öffentlichen Nahverkehr gibt es auch nicht. Keine Theater, keine Kinos, kein öffentlicher Nahverkehr.
Es gibt Busse, die von Firmen angestellt werden, um ihre Arbeiter da abzuholen, wo sie wohnen in ihren Siedlungen und zur Arbeit zu fahren, zur Baustelle oder in die Firma. Oder du hast Schulbusse, die du bezahlen kannst, aber die holen dann dein Kind an deiner Adresse ab. Aber es gibt nicht Buslinien, es gibt nicht U-Bahnen, es gibt nicht Straßenbahnen, es gibt Taxis und ansonsten hat jeder ein eigenes Auto. Es ist eine Autostadt, du kannst auch nicht laufen, weil die Entfernungen viel zu groß sind, es ist viel zu heiß. Du musst ein Auto besitzen oder in der Lage sein, dir einen Taxi oder einen Fahrer leisten zu können, weil sonst kommst du nicht von A nach B, dann gibt es keine Mobilität. Die bauen zwar sowohl in Riyadh, bauen sie an der U-Bahn, an der Metro, und in Jeddah ist es auch geplant, das wird aber noch lange dauern.
Konntest du Auto fahren?
Nee, ich konnte nicht Auto fahren. Ich habe tatsächlich noch nicht mal einen Führerschein, auch in Deutschland nicht, aber in Berlin ist das egal. In Berlin merke ich das nicht, weil in Berlin fahre ich mit der S-Bahn und mit dem Bus und kann laufen und Fahrrad fahren. Da stört mich das nicht. Wobei ich tatsächlich jetzt nach den zwei Jahren aus der Arabien bin, ich habe tatsächlich einen intensiven Wunsch mitgebracht, jetzt meinen Führerschein zu fahren. Man braucht das zwar in Berlin nicht, aber ich hatte das Gefühl, es wäre schon cool, die Option zu haben.
Also hättest du einen gehabt, hättest du dann...
Nein, hätte ich einen gehabt, hätte ich nicht fahren dürfen.
Weil es einfach...
Alle Frauen nicht fahren dürfen, kategorisch nicht. Prinzipiell nicht, nirgendwo. In Saudi-Arabien. Und da bist du halt schon ziemlich eingeschränkt.
Was macht man denn in einem Land, in dem es keine Kinos, keine Theaters, keine Konzerte, keine sonstigen... Also, bleibt da überhaupt noch irgendwas übrig? Also, außer jetzt Prayer-Time?
Es bleibt nicht wahnsinnig viel übrig. Also, ich hab mich zu beschäftigen gewusst. Ich hab regelmäßig mit Leuten Wanderungen in der Wüste gemacht. Ich bin an den Strand gefahren. Ich hab am Pool gechillt. Es gibt ein Aquarium, das man sich angucken kann in Jeddah. Es gibt natürlich alle diese Kultur-Dinge underground. Das sind dann halt keine öffentlichen Theater-Aufführungen und keine öffentlichen Musikveranstaltungen. Aber wenn du die richtigen Leute kennst, dann wirst du auch mal zu einer Hip-Hop-Party oder einer Album-Release-Party bei jemandem im Wohnzimmer eingeladen. Aber da sind dann 30 Leute. Das ist ganz geheim und du erfährst die Location eine Stunde vorher. Aber das sind keine öffentlichen Veranstaltungen. Ich kannte die Leute, weil das glücklicherweise zu meinem Job gehört hat, diese Leute zu kennen. Als Kulturbeauftragte musst du ja deine Kontakte in die Kulturszene haben. Die hatte ich. Wenn irgendwo was passiert ist, dann war ich da auch dabei. Aber da war ich halt in einer extrem privilegierten Situation. Ich habe oft genug andere Experts getroffen, Deutsche, aber auch andere, die haben gesagt haben, Mensch, hier ist ja überhaupt nichts los. Und da dachte ich so, na ja, man muss halt die richtigen Leute kennen. Also es ist halt eine Gesellschaft, wo das immer gilt. Es gilt immer, dass du die richtigen Leute kennen musst. Du kannst jedes Problem lösen, wenn du die richtigen Leute kennst sozusagen. Aber ansonsten ist da nicht viel.
Auch dein Kulturproblem kannst du lösen.
Auch mein Kulturproblem kannst du lösen, wenn du die richtigen Leute kennst. Aber trotzdem, das heißt nicht, dass da dann ein großes Angebot ist. Also da ist nicht viel los. Du kannst zwar Sachen machen. Es gibt ein paar Galerien und so, die du auch besuchen kannst. Aber insgesamt ist da nicht so viel. Und gerade für junge Leute, denen das jetzt irgendwie nicht zugänglich ist, diese Räume, diese alternativen Räume, die Leute gehen viel in Restaurants und essen viel und gerne. Das sind im Prinzip die einzigen öffentlichen Räume, an die man gehen kann, wo man sich aufhalten kann, wo nicht zu Hause ist.
Also man isst da eigentlich die ganze Zeit?
Nee, nicht die ganze Zeit. Aber wenn nicht Prayer-Time ist, dann geht man schon auch gerne essen. Das ist wirklich so eine Sache, die du machen kannst, wenn du dich mit Freunden triffst. Und gerade junge Männer machen viel so Drifting, so Spritztouren, Autos zu Schrott fahren, auf den Autobahnen zu bringen, in Richtung Wüste oder so. Und dann kennt man vielleicht auch von YouTube, von so Videos, so auf zwei Rädern fahren und sich aus den Fenstern hängen und auf dem Dach sitzen und solche Sachen. Kommen auch regelmäßig sehr viele Leute zu Tode. Generell ist der Autoverkehr in Saudi-Arabien extrem lebensgefährlich, die Leute fahren wie die Bekloppten. Ich glaube, das ist die höchste Sterberate im Autoverkehr auf der ganzen Welt. Ohne Mist jetzt, also wirklich, statistisch gesehen. Ich bin auch sehr, sehr froh, dass ich in den zwei Jahren nicht im Autoverkehr gestorben bin. Es gab verschiedene Stellen. Es war allein die Straßenführung, aber okay, das führt zu weit. Aber da gab es so einen U-Turn auf dem Weg zur Arbeit, wo ich wirklich jeden Morgen gesagt habe, lieber Gott, bitte lass mich nicht an dieser dummen Stelle, an diesem dummen U-Turn sterben. Weil der einfach wirklich super krass gefährlich ist. Und ich war zwei Wochen da, glaube ich, da habe ich meinen ersten Verkehrstoden gesehen. Aber ja, für junge Leute bleibt nicht viel übrig. Was sie tun könnten, was sie machen könnten, nicht viele Räume, in denen sie sich irgendwie kreativ äußern könnten, was sie machen könnten. Und da entsteht ein großes Frustrationpotenzial. Und ich glaube, dass gerade durch den ökonomischen Druck in den nächsten Jahren viel passieren muss. Also du hast halt diese jungen Leute, die irgendwie mitreden wollen, die auch teilweise einfach ein anderes Leben führen als die älteren Generationen. Also gerade, wir haben über Religion geredet. Religion spielt für die jüngeren Leute nicht mehr so eine krasse Rolle wie für die älteren. Die würden jetzt, die gehen vielleicht auch noch beten. Aber vielleicht nicht zu jeder Gebetszeit. Oder nicht jeder von denen. Oder ein Thema, das absolut tabu ist, über das man überhaupt nicht reden darf in Saudi-Arabien, ist zum Beispiel Atheismus. Es gibt im saudischen Weltbild keine Atheisten. Du kannst zum Beispiel auch, wenn du einreichst, musst du deine Religionszügehörigkeit angeben für dein Visum. Und du kannst nicht angeben, ich glaube an nichts. Im Zweifelsfall, wenn du aus der westlichen Welt kommst, trägst du im Zweifelsfall Christ ein. Ist total egal, woran du glaubst oder nicht glaubst, aber es gibt keine Atheisten. Das ist ein freies Feld und ich kannte tatsächlich einen, aber ist es klar, du musst im Prinzip Christ angeben und ich kannte einen einzigen Diplomaten, der das umgangen hat, indem er da eingetragen hat, Non-Muslim, weil er halt auch gesagt hat, ich glaub an nichts und das muss euch als Information reichen, dass ich nicht Islamisch bin, aber ich verrat euch auch nicht, was ich stattdessen bin, ich bin nämlich eigentlich nichts. So meine Konfession ist eigentlich nichts. Aber du kannst eigentlich nichts eintragen. Und gerade auch für junge... Weiß ich nicht, wie die Saudis das sehen. Aber gerade die jungen Saudis, für die ist Atheismus offiziell gesehen keine Option, aber real ist das extrem verbreitet. Aber das ist was, worüber die Leute nicht reden können. Das ist was, wo du dich nicht unbedingt trauen würdest, deinen Freunden, auch denen, mit denen du sehr eng bist, mitzuteilen, dass du übrigens da mal tief in dein Herz geguckt hast und festgestellt hast, dass du an gar keinen Gott glaubst. Das ist eine Gesellschaft, in der das keine Opposition, also keine...
Gibt's nicht. Gibt's nicht.
Gibt's nicht. Also fast genauso schlimm wie homosexuell sein.
Wie werden denn diese gesellschaftlichen Normen aufrechterhalten? Also inwiefern ist das eine Kontrolle und inwiefern ist es eine Selbstkontrolle?
Ja, da ist ganz viel Selbstkontrolle. Also weil du immer noch genug Leute hast, für die diese Werte und Normen total wichtig und total krass sind. Und du hast halt so eine, du hast eine gesellschaftliche Aushandlung, die im Prinzip jeden Tag an jedem Ort stattfindet, aber auch auf einer politischen Ebene zwischen den Kräften in der Gesellschaft, die es gerne immer noch konservativer hätten und noch strenger und noch religiöser und noch puristischer und den Kräften, die eigentlich gerne etwas mehr Öffnung und etwas mehr westlichen Lifestyle, etwas mehr Freiheiten hätten. Das sind so die beiden Pole, zwischen denen es sich bewegt. Und das Herrscherhaus hat eben auch die schwierige Aufgabe, irgendwie beide Gruppen glücklich zu machen. Und das ist langfristig halt auch so ein Balanceakt, wo ich nicht weiß, ob der endlos lange funktionieren wird. Weil... Wird schon immer gegeben haben. Aber alleine, wenn ich zurückdenke, ich habe meine Masterarbeit geschrieben über Frauen auf dem saudischen Arbeitsmarkt. 2013 hat der verstorbene König Abdullah so ein paar königliche Dekrete erlassen. Dann hat gesagt, ja, übrigens habe ich mir überlegt, ab morgen in allen Bekleidungs- und Unterwäschegeschäften für Frauen, Parfümerien, Apotheken, bla bla bla, sollen Frauen arbeiten können, damit Frauen Frauen bedienen. Wurde natürlich auch noch so ein bisschen religiös begründet. Geht ja nicht, dass Männer Frauen Frauenunterwäsche verkaufen. Aber was meinst du, was davon Aufschrei unter den konservativen, religiösen Eliten war, dass Frauen jetzt arbeiten können? Und da kommen die absurdesten Argumentationen, genau wie die absurdesten Argumentationen kommen, warum Frauen nicht Auto fahren können, weil das der Gebärmutterschäden schadet. Ohne Mist, das klingt wie die Argumente, die du in der westlichen Welt vor 150 Jahren gehört hast, warum Frauen nicht Fahrrad fahren dürfen. Schlecht für die Fruchtbarkeit. Für die geistige Gesundheit natürlich sowieso. Also da werden die bestimmt jetzt nie besponnen. Genau, also da hast du immer diesen Aushandlungsprozess und das hast du auf politischer Ebene. Und die Herrscherfamilie muss das irgendwie balancieren. Aber du merkst das natürlich auch im Alltag. Wenn ich die Straße runtergehe, dann sehe ich Menschen, dann fährt jemand an mir vorbei, der laut Hip-Hop-Musik hört. Und dann kann ich mir schon denken, welchem Lager der zuzuordnen ist. Und drei Schritte weiter kommt mir jemand entgegen, der mir zu rauhnt, ich soll doch mal besser meine Haare verschleiern, weil das angemessen wäre.
Was du aber nie gemacht hast?
Was ich nie gemacht habe? Na ja, warte, ich hab vielleicht, insgesamt in zwei Jahren hab ich vielleicht drei, viermal gemacht in speziellen Situationen. Ein oder zwei Situationen waren, wo wir offizielle Fotos für ein Projekt gemacht haben, die auch für verschiedene Zeitungen oder Printerzeugnisse verwendet werden sollten. Und da war dann klar, dass es einfacher für die, das zu verwenden, wenn ich zumindest so einen Alibi-Schal so einmal über dem Kopf drüber habe, wo dann nicht alles weg ist, aber wenigstens Alibi-Schal. Einmal, als ich abends von einer Veranstaltung nach Hause gekommen bin, da war es spät abends, ich war in einem Stadtviertel unterwegs, das ich nicht auskannte und dachte, jetzt möglichst wenig auffallen, einfach weil ich mich nur minimal unsicher gefühlt habe, einfach weil ich mich da nicht auskannte und das spät abends war und ich alleine unterwegs war. Und einmal, als ich irgendwie in den Norden geflogen bin und wir sind in Medina umgestiegen, und Medina ist halt auch eine heilige Stadt, und auch wenn der Flughafen außerhalb des Heiligen Bezirks, dem man als Nicht-Muslim nicht betreten darf, liegt, dachte ich so, das fände ich jetzt angemessener für alle die Menschen, die jetzt mit sehr großen religiösen Gefühlen unterwegs sind in Medina, dass ich die jetzt nicht mit meinen unverschleierten Haaren schocke. Aber ansonsten, ich bin auch nie irgendeiner dieser Aufforderungen nachgekommen, mir die Haare zu verschleiern.
Aber dir hat das schon gegeben.
Ja, aber das sind dann Leute, die wie gesagt an mir vorbeigehen und sagen Kavayr her und dann wahlweise entweder habe ich gesagt Inschallah oder ich habe irgendwie garstig geguckt oder habe so getan in meiner Handtasche, als würde ich nach dem Schal wühlen und drei Schritte weiter habe ich aufgehört, so zu tun. Das kannst du auch alles antworten im Prinzip. Also als Antwort auf Kavayr her ist es eine relativ freche Kritur. Kommt dann auf die Situation an. Aber auch das ist mir extrem selten passiert, dass jemand mich überhaupt aufgefordert hat, dass ich mein Haar verschleiße. Also auch vielleicht insgesamt fünf Mal oder so in den zwei Jahren.
Ja, wenn da Schleier getragen werden, es gibt da ja, gab es noch nicht so ein schönes Posting, wo irgendwie so alle verschiedenen Schleiervarianten der arabischen Welt, in dem man dann da, das hast du glaube ich auch noch mal verlegen, ne? Jetzt ist ja Saudi-Arabien so ein bisschen auch, weiß nicht, auf welchem Level von Verschleierung läuft das da so ab?
Ja, du musst gucken, es gibt da ganz unterschiedliche Leute, du siehst halt alles. Du siehst halt die Maximal-Verschleierungsvariante, die sogar noch über, also es gibt welche, die tragen, also Haare verschleiert sowieso, Hijab, dass die Haare verschleiert sind. Viele tragen dann dazu noch ein Gesichtsschleier vor dem Gesicht, Nikab heißt das, sodass nur noch die Augen frei sind. Und dann die absolute Extremvariante ist, wenn du dann noch ein weiteres zusätzliches, von innen durchsichtiges, aber von außen nicht durchsichtiges Tuch noch über den Kopf drüber ziehst, dann weißt du tatsächlich bei der Frau teilweise nicht, wo vorne und hinten ist, wenn sie so stark verschleiert ist. Weil du dann noch nicht mal die Augen siehst. Aber das siehst du extrem selten. Das ist so die extremste Variante. Viele Frauen tragen tatsächlich Niqab, also Gesichtsschleier, sodass du nur die Augen siehst. Aber wie gesagt, Jeddah zum Beispiel ist die liberalste und die weltoffenste und entspannteste Stadt in der Hinsicht in ganz Saudi-Arabien. Und da siehst du ganz viele Frauen, die halt auch so einen Alibi-Schleier tragen. Also halt so ein Tuch, was so locker über den Kopf geworfen ist, was auch ständig runterrutscht. Also so eine typische Geste, die du bei den Frauen siehst, während sie sich mit dir unterhalten oder im Café sitzen, dass sie ständig so an ihrem Tuch rumzubüllen und es wieder neu binden. Aber eigentlich zwei Sätze später ist es auch schon wieder runtergerutscht. Und das ist auch irgendwie hellblau mit pinken Sternen und Pailletten dran. Also dieser ganze...
Also es bricht auf.
In Jida auf jeden Fall. Aber alleine an der Farbe der Verschleierung oder auch der Abaya, die man trägt, die musste ich auch tragen. Und die hab ich auch getragen. Das ist so ein Mantel. So ein langer, durchsichtiger, dünner Mantel, den du über den, also nicht durchsichtig, aber sehr, sehr dünner Stoff, den du über der normalen Kleidung trägst. Das hab ich halt auch übergezogen. Alleine bei den Farben siehst du zum Beispiel in Riyadh, der Hauptstadt, was als besonders konservativ gilt, die tragen nur schwarz. Wenn ich nach Riyadh fahre zu einer Geschäftsreise, dann nehme ich meine schlichteste, langweiligste, blödeste schwarze Abaya aus dem Schrank und fahre nach Riyadh. Aber in Jida bei einer Veranstaltung trage ich auch mal eine, die irgendwie dunkelblau mit silberner Spitze am Rand ist oder eine, die grau und pink und hellblau und in Pastel töten ist. Und da gibt's halt die verrücktesten Sachen in Jida. Da gibt's jetzt, da gibt's wirklich, das ist eine Fashion und du siehst auch sofort, also ich hab da jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel Geld verpulvert für schicke Abayas, weil ich ja dann im Endeffekt auch nur zwei Jahre da war, aber preislich ist da nach oben das Sky the Limit. Es gibt wirklich viele verschiedene Fashion-Stile bei den Abayas, die einfach den Grundgedanken, dass es darum geht, dass die Frau sich bescheiden kleidet und ihre Reize versteckt wirklich komplett konterkarieren. Weil es gibt Abayas, die sind im Punk-Style, die haben dann hier so Spikes auf den Schultern oder es gibt welche, die sind ab dem Knie bis zum Boden aus durchsichtigem Stoff, damit du die teuren Schuhe siehst, die sie anhaben, zum Beispiel, die du an der Teile zusammenbinden kannst, mit Taschen, Reißverschluss und Kapuze, mit Zwarowski-Steinen hinten drauf. Also die verrücktesten Sachen. In jeder siehst du das alles. Es bröckelt, aber der wichtigste Punkt ist einfach, du hast bei allen, es gibt ganz viele unterschiedliche Leute, es gibt ganz unterschiedlich individuelles religiöses Empfinden, die Familien sehen das unterschiedlich, wie stark du dich verschleierst als Frau oder nicht, wie viele Freiheiten du als Frau hast oder nicht, hängt von dir selber und deiner Familie und deinem Umfeld ab. Also es gibt einfach ganz, ganz viele unterschiedliche Ausprägungen, würde ich sagen. Du kannst es nie über einen Kamm scheren.
Jetzt wird ja immer viel so über Menschenrechte geredet, wenn man mit Saudi-Arabien zu tun hat. Das ist natürlich auch immer so eine Standardkeule, die kann man natürlich auch immer auspacken. Als wie ungerecht hast du denn alles, was du in den letzten Jahren gemacht hast? Und hast du wahrgenommen, was so um dich herum geschehen ist? Ist das eigentlich erst mal primär nur merkwürdig? Oder hast du das Gefühl, dass ungerecht umgegangen wird?
Ja, schon. Ich persönlich empfinde das schon als ungerecht. Aber das ist vergleichbar mit dem Gefühl, was ich auch in Ägypten zum Beispiel hatte. Dieses Gefühl, dass du je nachdem, wer du bist, wo du in der sozialen Schicht bist, wie viel Geld du hast, wie viel Einfluss du hast, wie viel politischen Macht du hast, es sind einfach nicht alle gleich vor dem Gesetz. So sind einfach die Gesellschaften. Und das ist in Ägypten genauso wie in Saudi-Arabien halt unterschiedlich ausgeprägt und so. Und es kommt auf den Fall an und so weiter. Aber im Großen und Ganzen habe ich immer einen ganz starken Eindruck bekommen, es sind nicht alle gleich vor dem Gesetz. Du kannst dich mit Geld und Einfluss und den richtigen Leuten, die du kennst, aus jedem Problem rauskaufen. Es ist egal, ob du eine Straßenverkehrsregel missachtet hast und dem Straßenpolizist einfach, weiß ich nicht, 100 Rial in die Hand drückst und sagst, ich bin hier gar nicht über Rot gefahren. Oder ob du sagst, mein Vater ist übrigens der XY, es ist ja besser, wenn du mir jetzt keinen Strafzettel schreibst und dann macht er das auch nicht. Bis zu Mordfällen, Korruption, egal. Egal was du für ein Problem hast, mit Geld und Einfluss kannst du dich aus allem rauswieseln und wenn du kein Geld und keinen Einfluss hast, dann kann schon das kleinste Problem für dich das Ende deines Weges bedeuten. Und das empfinde ich als sehr ungerecht. Und du merkst zum Beispiel auch, wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel mal über die Hinrichtungsfälle reden, es gibt einfach bestimmte Straftaten, die nach saudischen Recht, das auf der Scharia beruht, mit dem Tode bestraft werden. Zum Beispiel Mord oder auch Vergewaltigung oder auch Handeln mit Rauschgift zum Beispiel. Also wenn du irgendwie mit Gras erwischt wirst oder mit Pillen oder so und irgendwie klar ist, du hast das konsumiert und oder vertrieben, dann steht da auf die Todesstrafe zu. Aber nicht jeder wird deswegen zwingend, wenn er eins dieser Verbrechen begangen hat, auch gleichermaßen bestraft. Du siehst halt einfach, wenn man sich anguckt, welche Leute werden denn tatsächlich für diese Verbrechen hingerichtet, dann siehst du, dass das ganz viele arme Leute sind, dass das ganz viele Gastarbeiter sind, die zum Beispiel mit Drogen gehandelt haben. Es gibt einen hohen Drogenkonsum in Saudi-Arabien, das weiß auch keiner, aber es gibt ein großes Drogenproblem. Es gibt Drogenentzugskliniken und viele Aufklärungskampagnen an Universitäten, wo du immer denkst, so die gebe es nicht, wenn es da nicht wirklich ein großes Problem mitgebe, mit Drogenmissbrauch. Und ja, es sind dann arme Leute, die einfach nicht anders sich daraus wieseln können. Oder zum Beispiel bei Mord, gibt es die Optionen in der Scharia, da wird es jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert, aber ich reiß das mal kurz an. Es kann zum Beispiel Blutgeld bezahlt werden. Es gibt verschiedene Optionen, wie du, wenn du für Mord angeklagt wirst und eigentlich auch schon verurteilt wurdest zum Tode, wie es dazu kommen kann, dass du doch nicht hingerichtet wirst, weil zum Beispiel der König ein königliches Patron ausspricht. So, kann er halt. Und wenn du die richtigen Leute kennst, oder deine Familie bei den richtigen Leuten Gehör findet und die dem König den Zettel zur Unterschrift vorlegen, hiermit erlasse ich x, y die Todesstrafe, dann bist du halt nicht hingerichtet. So, also das kannst du schon mal lösen. Dann kann die Familie des oder der Geschädigten, der Person, die du zum Beispiel umgebracht hast, kann dir verzeihen. So, geht halt im Schalierrecht, kann sagen, hiermit verzeih ich dir, jetzt ist es nur noch lebenslang statt Todesstrafe. Und du kannst aber, es gibt auch Optionen, wo du zum Beispiel der Familie des oder der Geschädigten das Blutgeld bezahlst und dann verzeihen sie dir. Und das wird aber teilweise auch missbrauchen. Und wenn das Blutgeld halt eine astronomische Summe ist, die du an die Familie oder der Geschädigten zahlen müsstest, damit sie dir vergeben, damit du nur lebenslang bekommst und nicht hingerichtet wirst und du aber diese Summe nicht bezahlen kannst, dann wirst du halt hingerichtet.
So.
Und das sind einfach nur ein paar Beispiele dafür, dass vor dem Gesetz nicht alle gleich sind. Das empfinde ich tatsächlich als ungerecht. Und da bin ich, auch wenn ich in den linken Kreisen, in denen ich hier in Berlin stecke, ganz viele Fehler des deutschen Rechtsstaates sehe. Und irgendwie auch hier immer viel von Polizeigewalt und Missbrauch von Autoritäten, Korruption. Wir haben das auch alles, aber das ist ein ganz anderes Level. Und dann weiß man plötzlich, dass man sich den deutschen Rechtsstaat in einer gewissen Hinsicht doch auch wieder so ein bisschen zu schätzen.
Wie muss man sich denn überhaupt das Verhältnis von Saudi-Arabien und in gewisser Hinsicht kann man das jetzt vielleicht auch mal wieder auf die ganze arabische Welt ausdehnen zum Westen oder unserem Kulturkreis eigentlich vorstellen? Was, also ich hab immer wieder gemerkt, es ist ja immer so leicht, nicht wahr? Dinge sind da irgendwie anders und dann hat man so seine Feindbilder natürlich auch schnell parat, weil man eben nicht nachvollziehen kann, warum das so ist. Und da irgendeine besondere, was heißt ich, manche vermuten da eine gewisse Boshaftigkeit oder eine inhärente Schlechtigkeit oder was es auch immer ist. Oder man versteht es halt auch einfach nicht und kriegt es nicht gewechselt und naja, bezeichnet es eben als was auch immer man das eben gerade bezeichnen möchte. Häufig habe ich aber festgestellt, ja, die Dinge sind dann irgendwie anders, aber sie fußen eben auf fundamentalen Annahmen, die einfach andere sind als wir im Verhältnis zu, welche Rolle spielt bei uns Religion, welche Rolle...
Der Familienverbund zum Beispiel.
Spielt Familie, welche Rolle spielt das Staatssystem oder eben auch einfach so Aspekte, die wir gar nicht sehen. Also, dass auf einmal Dinge da eine Rolle spielen, auf die man einfach im Traum nicht gekommen wäre, dass das überhaupt eine Rolle spielen kann. Also das ist jetzt so ein bisschen meine Vermutung. Wie würdest du das Bild, was die westliche Gesellschaft im arabischen Raum hat, also vielleicht mal so von Hollywood-Einflüssen mal abgesehen, sondern sozusagen so, was denken die sich?
Über uns jetzt.
Über uns? Wie stehen dem gegenüber? Ist es einfach schwierig da zu reden, weil die Dinge einfach so unterschiedlich sind oder wo ist man sich vielleicht auch näher als man glaubt?
Also, hängt natürlich auch wieder davon ab, mit wem du redest. Also wer dein Gesprächspartner oder deine Gesprächspartnerin ist und was die für eine Sicht haben, du kannst da alles antreffen von einer sehr freundlichen, positiven Sicht auf die westliche Welt. Also gerade als Deutscher haben die halt dann so typisch deutsche Klischees von uns im Kopf. Du sagst, du bist aus Deutschland und dann sagen die irgendwie Mercedes und Fußball oder so. Also Deutschland wird als ganz tolle, hochqualitative Industrienation wahrgenommen. Fußball spielt eine große Rolle in Saudi-Arabien, das heißt Deutschland ist da auch ganz vorne mit dabei. Deutsche Pünktlichkeit, deutsche Zuverlässigkeit. Deutsche werden so ein bisschen als humorlos wahrgenommen, aber als extrem zuverlässig und die arbeiten sehr hart. Das ist so das Klischee, was man in dieser Region von den Deutschen hat. Was man so im Kopf hat.
Ich würde sogar sagen, das ist eigentlich auch ein globales deutsches Klischee. Ich würde auch sagen, da ist auch was dran.
Und die kaufen dann halt zum Beispiel auch Baufahrzeuge aus Deutschland oder von mittelständischen Unternehmen kaufen sie gerne. Irgendwelche Dinge, die sie für ihre Industrie gebrauchen können, irgendwelche kleinen.
Das ist nicht so ganz das, worauf ich jetzt hinaus wollte. Das konnte ich mir schon vorstellen. Das habe ich auch in vielen Ländern so angetroffen. Klar, man hat so von jedem Land so seine Vorstellung. Aber ich meine, jenseits der Klischees. Also sagen wir mal selbst, sie würden alles wissen, wie wir denken und was unsere Ansichten sind, was sicherlich nicht immer der Fall ist und teilweise Klischee geprägt. Wo würden sie aber dann trotzdem zu anderen Schlüssen kommen? Weil sie einfach andere Dinge anders wertschätzen. Also ich meine, ein bisschen zeichnet sich das schon ab in diesem merkwürdigen Verhältnis zu dieser Herrscherfamilie, dass man das halt einfach so hin nimmt. Das haben wir ja nun schränkenweise auch gehabt.
Naja, also viele Sachen sind einfach, es ist wirklich einfach alles durch die Religion eingefärbt. Alleine die Menschen in Deutschland sind ja auch einfach heute nicht mehr so religiös wie früher zum Beispiel. Das spielt im Alltag nicht mehr so eine Rolle. Und zum Beispiel, ich habe mich im Rahmen meines Studiums auch mit islamischen Feminismus beschäftigt. Und es gibt viele Strömungen im islamischen Feminismus, die den westlichen Feminismus ablehnen, weil sie sagen, das ist euer Ding und das mag für euch okay sein. Wobei eigentlich haben wir das Gefühl, ihr habt auch nicht nur positive Sachen daraus gewonnen. Wir wollen eure Fehler nicht machen, bei uns funktioniert das anders. Wir haben unseren eigenen Feminismus und der ist dann zum Beispiel auch religiös begründet. Aus dem Koran zum Beispiel. Nicht unbedingt aus den allgemeinen universalen Menschenrechten, sondern zum Beispiel aus dem, die versuchen...
Den Koran auch neu zu interpretieren.
Genau. Das ist ein Beispiel und das ergibt natürlich auch jetzt nicht nur intellektuell, sondern auch einfach strategisch ergibt das Sinn, weil wenn du natürlich in einer Gesellschaft wie z.B. Saudi-Arabien versuchst bestimmte Rechte oder Freiräume für Frauen zu erkämpfen, in einer Gesellschaft, die so stark konservativ-religiös geprägt ist, ergibt das natürlich Sinn, wenn du das den Leuten auch religiös verkaufen kannst. Wie ich vorhin meinte, du kannst halt den Leuten besser verkaufen. Frauen sollten in Unterwäsche-Geschäften für Frauen arbeiten, als Angestellte im Einzelhandel, weil das ja wohl nicht geht. Dass fremde Männer, Frauen, die sie nicht kennen, denen sie nicht verheiratet sind, ihre BHs verkaufen. Das ist halt eine Argumentationsstruktur, die du verwenden kannst, die Leute verstehen können. Und im Endeffekt hast du ganz viele Arbeitsplätze für saudische Frauen geschaffen, aber halt auf dem Rücken einer religiösen Argumentationsstruktur. Und das funktioniert im islamischen Feminismus halt an vielen Stellen. Und das Gleiche gilt tatsächlich auch an anderen Stellen. Zum Beispiel gibt es verschiedene, stark durch den Islam geprägte Staaten, wie zum Beispiel Saudi-Arabien oder Iran, die eine Alternative zur allgemeinen Erklärung der Menschenrechte haben. Da gab es 1990 die Cairo Declaration of Human Rights in Islam, wo mehrere Staaten der arabisch-islamischen Welt, die sich in der Organisation of Islamic Cooperation, was sowas wie die UNO für arabisch-islamische Staaten ist, zusammengeschlossen haben und die haben gesagt, naja, universelle Menschenrechte sind zwar eigentlich ganz gut, aber irgendwie doch aus so einer sehr westlichen Perspektive und das hat nicht unbedingt alles mit unserer Lebenswelt zu tun. Und wir nehmen das mal und machen das mal in islamisch. Und da stehen halt, das ist dann stärker an der Scharia orientiert, aber da ist dann zum Beispiel Gender Equality noch mal ganz anders definiert. Da heißt es dann, die Frau hat die gleiche Würde und die gleichen religiösen Rechte und Pflichte, aber daraus, Frau ist zum Beispiel in vielen Staaten, wo sich das Recht auf der Scharia begründet, vor allem im Gericht ist ihre Aussage nicht gleichwertig mit der eines Mannes zum Beispiel. So und das geht natürlich nach der Erklärung der allgemeinen Menschenrechte nicht, weil da ist ja jeder vor dem Gesetz gleich. So, also wie gesagt, diese religiöse Einfärbung durchdringt einfach alles, vieles.
Was ist denn das Verhältnis von Saudi-Arabien zu seinen Nachbarländern? Man hat so ein bisschen, also ich weiß nicht, ob so viele Leute so den Unterschied zwischen zum Beispiel den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten, also Dubai, Abu Dhabi, zu Saudi-Arabien herziehen können. Kuwait ist sicherlich auch noch so ein Ding. Bahrain, was gibt es noch? Eins habe ich noch vergessen.
Jemund und Oman.
Jemund und Oman, ja, die sind ja so im, das sind ja nicht solche Emirate in dem Sinne, oder?
Qatar, Kuwait, Bahrain und die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate sind die kleinen Golfstaaten.
Was stecken die alle unter einer Decke? Ist das irgendwie ganz was anderes? Sind das nur die paar, die nicht rechtzeitig bekämpft wurden?
Die sind schon alle ziemlich gute Buddies, also Saudi-Arabien und jetzt diese Golfstaaten, von denen wir jetzt reden, die am persischen Golf liegen. Die sind ja auch alle zusammen im Golf-Kooperationsrat, was man jetzt sehr grob vereinfacht mal als Mini-EU sehen könnte. Die sich also sehr eng absprechen und auch sehr eng miteinander kooperieren. Sich auch zum Beispiel darüber absprechen, also im Golf-Kooperationsrat ist zum Beispiel auch Oman mit drin. Und die sich zum Beispiel über den Ölpreis absprechen und die Ölforderungen und solche Dinge und das gemeinsam miteinander abklären. Es ist tatsächlich auch schon seit vielen Jahren im Gespräch gewesen, dass die Länder des Golf-Kooperationsrats eine gemeinsame einheitliche Wirtschaftszone einrichten wollen. Eben auch so ein bisschen analog zur EU. Aber ich hab das Gefühl, das wird auch nie passieren. Da wird schon sehr, sehr lange drüber geredet. Und da ist bisher nicht so viel passiert. Und die haben eben ein gutes Verhältnis zueinander. Und politisch sprechen die sich auch sehr viel ab und wirtschaftlich. Saudi-Arabien ist halt so der große Bruder, ne? Also wenn das Geschwisterstaaten sind, ist Saudi-Arabien immer der große Bruder. Und wenn Saudi-Arabien die Marschrichtung politisch vorgibt, dann ziehen die auch immer alle hinterher. Weil Saudi-Arabien in der Region einfach sehr einflussreich ist. Also wenn Saudi-Arabien gerade Streit mit dem Iran hat oder mit Schweden und es da politische Auseinandersetzungen gibt und Saudi-Arabien zieht den Botschafter aus Schweden zum Beispiel ab oder aus Iran, das beides vorgekommen ist im letzten Jahr, dann ziehen die anderen sofort hinterher. Als Erster zieht Bahrain hinterher und dann kommt häufig Kuwait noch hinterher und die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate, die ziehen dann immer nach. Und auch kulturell ist das relativ ähnlich. Also wenn man zum Beispiel in die Emirate reist, die Emirate sind zwar auch jetzt für die westliche Welt immer mehr in zunehmendem Maße ein beliebtes Tourismusziel, aber das sind trotzdem auch immer noch eigentlich sehr, sehr konservative, stark islamisch geprägte religiöse Staaten, die auch ähnlich strukturiert sind. Da heißt es dann halt nicht König, da ist dann halt ein Schech der Herrscher jeweils, also zum Beispiel in den Emiraten, jedes Emirat hat einen eigenen Schech, aber die Struktur ist ganz ähnlich, also die Ausrichtung ist ganz ähnlich, das sind auch alles absolute Herrscherstrukturen. Also mit den Golfstaaten ist Saudi-Arabien eigentlich relativ close, sehr, sehr enges Verhältnis auch zu Ägypten. Jetzt gerade war der saudische König für eine ganze Woche in Ägypten, um sich mit Sisi abzusprechen. Die haben riesige Wirtschaftsabkommen unterzeichnet, die wollen eine Brücke bauen, über das Rote Meer von Saudi-Arabien nach Ägypten, riesige Powerplans bauen auf dem Sinai, also da ist richtig, richtig viel Geld. Und die sind sowohl politisch als auch wirtschaftlich sehr eng verwandelt, Ägypten und Saudi-Arabien. Dann hat Saudi-Arabien noch gutes Verhältnis zu Jordanien, weil das jordanische Herrscherhaus, äh, sie haben quasi gemeinsame Vorfahren. Die sind sehr, sehr weitläufig miteinander verwandt. Das haschemitische Herrscherhaus von Jordanien und die saudische Königsfamilie, deswegen sind die auch noch relativ eng. Aber sehr kritisch ist natürlich das Verhältnis zu Jemen und auch zu Irak. Also im Norden wird seit, ich glaube, anderthalb Jahren oder so wird ein Zaun oder eine Mauer gebaut mitten durch die Wüste. Also an der Grenze zwischen Saudi-Arabien und Irak, was im Wesentlichen so die Infiltration durch Schmuggler und IS-Kämpfer und Terroristen und so weiter bekämpfen soll. Und im Jemen führt Saudi-Arabien seit, seit einem Jahr oder anderthalb, führt Krieg im Jemen, genau, gegen die Judis. Wobei es sehr wichtig ist, immer zu betonen, dass Saudi-Arabien völkerrechtlich gesehen nicht mit dem Jemen Krieg führt, sondern im Jemen. Weil die international anerkannte Regierung vom Jemen, der international anerkannte gewählte Präsident des Jemen, wird von Saudi-Arabien unterstützt, ist sozusagen im Exil, in der Exil-Regierung gewesen, in Saudi-Arabien lange. Und sie kämpfen ja sozusagen im Jemen, um diese international anerkannte Regierung wieder einzusetzen. Deswegen völkerrechtlich gesehen sind die beiden Länder nicht miteinander im Krieg. Auch wenn man es denken könnte, wenn man hört, Saudi-Arabien fliegt über Jemen und wirft da Bomben ab. Aber das ist super kompliziert im Jemen.
Ja genau, das fassen wir jetzt auch nicht auf. Ich wollte nur mal so ein bisschen die Rolle von Saudi-Arabien verstehen, weil also würde es aber unterstreichen, dass sozusagen diese Platzhirschrolle, die ist, sagen wir mal, die ist real. Sie haben am meisten Geld und sie stehen eigentlich mit allen in Verbindung, wenn ich unter einer Decke.
Wobei du halt sehen musst, dass diese Platzhirschfunktion jetzt extrem in Gefahr sehen, aus verschiedensten Gründen. Ein wichtiger Grund, und viele der Konflikte in der Region haben zu tun mit dem Krieg, oder was heißt mit dem Krieg, mit dem Konflikt, mit dem Streit zwischen Saudi-Arabien und Iran. Weil Iran ist der andere Platzhirsch. Saudi-Arabien und Iran sind die beiden großen Jungs auf dem Schulhof sozusagen. Und gerade dadurch, dass der Iran jetzt sich wieder stärker an den Westen annähert und jetzt nicht mehr so abgeschottet wird und die Sanktionen abgebaut werden und so weiter, hat Saudi-Arabien plötzlich Angst, dass Iran der etwas beliebtere Bruder von ihnen beiden wird. Und dass der Westen jetzt plötzlich mit dem Iran spielt. Iran war lange nicht mehr so eine große Sorge für Saudi-Arabien, weil Iran war isoliert und hat politisch nicht so eine große Rolle gespielt. Und die großen westlichen Nationen haben sich alle in Richtung Saudi-Arabien ausgerichtet. Also gerade die USA haben seit Jahren und Jahrzehnten sind die auf Saudi-Arabien fokussiert, haben da ihre militärischen Bases, sind irgendwie in der Ölförderung mit der Aramco-Firma, sind da irgendwie total mit drin. Also USA und Saudi-Arabien sind super eng verwandelt. Und jetzt schauen die USA eben auch in Richtung Iran. Und das lässt bei Saudi-Arabien so ein Gefühl von enttäuschter Liebe zurück.
Und auch Europa, auch Deutschland auch. Die haben nun auch schon immer ganz gut dabei waren in Saudi-Arabien. Mit Panzern, mit anderen Waffen, Gerüst und so. Muss man ja auch keine Illusion machen. Also es handelt sich dabei auch um ein extrem hochgerüstetes Land. Also diesen Krieg da unten können die sich auch mal locker jetzt mal aus ihrem Lager rausrollen. Dafür haben sie lange genug gekauft. Und naja, sie leben halt auch so ein bisschen eben in der Angst vor dem Iran. Das ist ja schon angesprochen. Weil ja, muss man sich auch noch mal klar machen, Iran und Saudi-Arabien ja dann im Wesentlichen auch wirklich so die scharfkantigste Grenze zwischen dem Sunnitismus und...
Sunnismus und Shi'ismus.
Sunnismus heißt schon wieder ein IT. Ich bau überall mal IT ein.
Genau, Sunnismus und Shi'ismus, ja.
Genau, also Sunniten und Shi'iten stehen sich hier im Prinzip gegenüber. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass es jetzt gar keine Shi'iten im Saudi-Arabien gibt.
Nein, nein, es gibt eine shi'itische Minderheit in Saudi-Arabien. Die wird allerdings sehr stark politisch unterdrückt. Die leben fast alle im Ostteil des Landes, in der Ostprovinz. Und deswegen knallt es da auch ständig wieder. Also da kommt es immer wieder zu Demonstrationen, die da niedergeknüppelt werden. Gerade Anfang des Jahres 2016 gab es ja jetzt mehrere Hinrichtungen, wo mehrere der Führer, der shi'itischen Führer aus der Ostprovinz hingerichtet wurden. Da war schon immer Unrest. Die werden politisch benachteiligt und unterdrückt, muss man einfach so sagen. Und deswegen sollte man da auch zum Beispiel nicht hinreisen, weil da ist einfach immer Unruhe. Aber nicht nur, aber vor allem in der Ostprovinz lebt die shi'itische Minderheit in Saudi-Arabien. Dann hast du im Nachbarstaat Bahrain hast du eine shi'itische Mehrheit auf der Insel Bahrain, die allerdings von einer sunnitischen Herrscherfamilie beherrscht wird. Also da hast du die Situation, dass eine religiöse Minderheit eine religiöse Mehrheit eigentlich beherrscht, was auch jede Menge Konfliktpotenzial birft.
Ja, auch in Syrien.
Genau, in Syrien auch. Und deswegen kracht das auch in Bahrain immer wieder. Und es kommt zu Demonstrationen, die dann unterdrückt und niedergeschlagen werden. Genau, wie du schon gesagt hast, scharfkantige Grenze zwischen Iran und Saudi-Arabien, zwischen Sunniten und Shi'iten. Und die führen halt so Stellvertreterkriege, sowohl in Syrien als auch in Jemen. Also es sind sehr, sehr komplizierte, schwierige, komplexe Konflikte in beiden Fällen, sowohl in Syrien als auch in Jemen, wo ganz, ganz viele verschiedene Sachen zusammenspielen und Fraktionen und unterschiedliche Interessen und eine komplizierte Geschichte und die Stämme und bla, bla, bla, bla. Aber unter anderem sind es auch Stellvertreterkriege. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein wichtiger Faktor in beiden Konflikten. Und es ist eigentlich interessant und ich hab mich auch immer wieder gefragt, ob irgendwann der Tag kommt, wo Iran und Saudi-Arabien der Stellvertreterkriege müde sind und sich einfach mal straight out gegenseitig den Krieg erklären. Und immer mal wieder kommt es zu diplomatischen Spannungen, wo du denkst, oh, jetzt ist es gar nicht mehr so weit weg, weil nachdem Saudi-Arabien eben diese schiitischen Führer hingerichtet hatte Anfang des Jahres, kam es im Iran zu großen Demonstrationen. Da ist unter anderem die saudische Botschaft abgefackelt worden bei den Demonstrationen. Daraufhin war Saudi-Arabien sehr empört und hat die kompletten diplomatischen Beziehungen zu Iran abgebrochen. Daraufhin sind die anderen Golfstaaten nachgezogen und haben auch die diplomatischen Beziehungen abgebrochen. Und jetzt herrschten nochmal mehr Eiszeit zwischen Iran und Saudi-Arabien als vorher.
Aber es gibt ja in dem Sinne gar keine gemeinsame Grenze. Also wenn man jetzt mal vom persischen Golf absieht, da liegt halt noch ein bisschen Wasser und irgendwo sind sie ein bisschen näher dran aneinander. Ich weiß es nicht ganz genau. Ach nee, das ist ja auch schon alles Oman, Bahrain. Also so viel ist es jetzt gar nicht. Nur so im Norden eigentlich, so unterhalb von Kuwait. Da haben sie dann nochmal so ein paar Kilometer zu überbrücken. Also ich weiß nicht so richtig ganz genau, was da so in einem Kriegsfalle gewonnen werden soll. Zumal Saudi-Arabien am persischen Golf eigentlich auch überhaupt keine Kapitale hat. Also ich meine, das ist ja eigentlich nur Riyadh. Das ist mitten in der Wüste. Und der Rest ist halt Oman, Abu Dhabi, Dubai, Katar, Bahrain und Kuba. Sonst ist da ja nichts.
Das ergibt auch überhaupt keinen Sinn. Aber das ist häufig so, wenn Leute sich sehr irrational und sehr intensiv hassen, dass es nicht so viel Sinn ergibt. Also ich finde zum Beispiel total interessant, aber auch total krass. Mir ist wirklich aufgefallen in der saudischen Tagespresse, wenn man saudische Tageszeitungen liest, wie im Laufe der letzten ein, zwei Jahre das Maß an anti-iranischer Propaganda und auch vollkommen absurden Verschwörungstheorien, die irgendwie den Iran einziehen, zugenommen haben, als wirklich ernst gemeinte Nachrichtenmeldungen. So was wie die zehn größten Konflikte, wo Iran in den letzten Jahren die Finger im Spiel hatte. Das geht schon fast, das ist wirklich...
Ja. Beim dritten musste ich weinen.
Ja, aber das geht wirklich, das ist wirklich so absurd. Das geht wirklich schon fast so in diese Richtung so, warum in Wahrheit Iran hinter 9-11 gesteckt hat. Ohne Scheiß, ohne Scheiß. Ich hab, es gab Artikel, wo ich wirklich dachte, ich lese nicht richtig so was wie, die folgenden Attentäter hatten irgendwie Beziehungen zu Iran. Und ich dachte so, ich kann nicht glauben, dass ich das in einer saudischen Tageszeitung lese, wo doch einfach mal alle Welt weiß, dass ein Großteil der Attentäter aus Saudi-Arabien gekommen ist.
Einschließlich des Oberchefs.
Ja, und es ist halt wirklich krass, wenn du dir einfach anguckst, welchen Umfang diese anti-iranische Propaganda genommen hat, die irgendwie an die Leute gefüttert wird und die auch wirklich durch alle Schichten geht. Ich bin auch immer total irritiert gewesen, wenn ich mich mit Leuten unterhalten habe, die dann diese anti-iranischen Ressentiments mir gegenüber auch geäußert haben und total überzeugt davon sind, die aber gefühlt als vollkommen unbegründet und bodenlos wahrgenommen haben. Also, wo ich dann gesagt hätte, man warst das letzte Mal im Iran, was hast du persönlich für ein Problem mit dem Iran? Das ist dann total unbegründet, aber wie das immer bei so Ressentiments ist, am meisten hat man die Leute, die man gar nicht so gut kennt.
Ja, genau, das können wir ja in Deutschland auch gerade wieder wunderbar beobachten. Das ist halt so das Problem. Stellt sich die Frage, wo geht es eigentlich hin mit dieser Region? Ich weiß, gerade Fragen, die die Zukunft betreffen, sind immer nicht so einfach zu beantworten. Ich kenne jetzt diese Region persönlich eigentlich kaum. Meine einzigen Berührungspunkte waren, naja, ich war mal so ein bisschen in Israel ein wenig und ich kenne Dubai ein ganz kleines bisschen, weil ich da mal ein, zwei Tage verbracht habe. Was allerdings? Warst du mal in Dubai? Ja, auch klar. Also mit diesen ganzen aufgeschütteten Inseln und so weiter, das ging, als ich da war, ging das gerade erst los. Da war jetzt auch noch der große Wolkenkratzer noch nicht fertig und Pipapo, aber man merkt ja halt schon, okay, ihr macht hier, ihr fahrt hier einfach mal echt fett auf. Das ist ja ganz offensichtlich. Und das sind in den letzten Jahren dann nicht anders geworden. Aber wie du es auch schon angesprochen hast, sie ziehen halt auch im zunehmenden Maße international agierende Universitäten an, insbesondere amerikanische, die da alle ihre Niederlassungen gründen.
Kunstgalerien. Du hast irgendwie die Niederlassung vom Louvre da. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob genau in Dubai, aber da in den Golfstaaten. Also Kunst. In Qatar ist dieses riesige Kunstmuseum. Also Kunst, Bildung, Tourismus. Also die Golfstaaten sind gut in der Diversifizierung, sagen wir mal so.
Das ist jetzt nicht Saudi-Arabien, aber wir müssen ja nicht unbedingt direkt dabei bleiben. Aber die sind ja nun kulturell alle so weit miteinander verzahnt, dass das mittelfristig auch alles aufeinander abfärben könnte. Und gerade so Abu, also vereinigte arabische Emirate, also Abu Dhabi, Dubai liegen ja direkt nebeneinander. Also zumindest fährt man da schon um eine Stunde mit dem Auto oder so. Und riesige Dinge, aber vor allem auch ein unglaublich durchglobalisierter Ort. Also die Zahl von internationalen Menschen, die jetzt nicht auch nur so als Gastarbeiter im Sinne von ich baue euch hier mal ein Stadion und ein Stab dabei, sondern die da einfach große Logistikunternehmen fahren, das ist ja dann ein Riesenthema. Die haben sich da als Drehkreuz eigentlich der arabischen Welt etabliert, also des gesamten Raums etabliert. Ich glaube, es gibt da keinen nennenswertes anderes, wo so viele Flugzeuge durchgehen. Der Hafen spielt sicherlich noch eine Rolle. Also da entsteht ein unglaublich internationaler Ort mit sehr viel mehr Lebendigkeit, der mehr ist als nur ein paar verrückter Araber mit zu viel Geld bauen sich da einen Spielplatz an. Da ist sozusagen die Welt zu Hause. Und sowas kann ja eigentlich langfristig nicht ohne Folgen bleiben. Das ist so ein bisschen der Spin, den ich jetzt hier irgendwie versuche, an den Start zu kriegen, ganz unbeholfen. Denkst du, dass, also was geht dir durch den Kopf, wenn du auf dieser einen Seite diese unglaubliche Verfangenheit in so einer Jahrhunderte alten Religions- Tradition auf der einen Seite siehst, wo auf der anderen Seite einen durch diese Unmengen an Mitteln, die dieses ganze Ölgeschäft über die Jahrzehnte eingebracht hat, diesen Bauwahn, dieser extrem hohe Lebensstandard und natürlich ist ein zunehmender Maße auch der Einfluss des Netzes, der sich ja auch nicht fernhalten lässt, auch wenn wir natürlich dauerlich am Filtern und Zensieren sind. Wo geht die Reise hin? Wie muss man diese Region nehmen? Was wird da passieren?
Naja, schwierig. Also, ich denke schon, dass die Region sich noch ganz stark verändern wird in den nächsten Jahren. Ich glaube, da geht es einfach total ab. Also jedes Jahr bringt riesige Veränderungen. Das war auch einer der Gründe, warum ich da überhaupt hinwollte, weil ich wusste, das ist ein Land, wo die Gesellschaft im Umbruch ist und ich will live dabei sein. Ich will live angucken, wie Dinge passieren. Also von außen sieht das so aus, als ob sich die Dinge in Saudi-Arabien in so einer sehr, sehr langsamen Gletschergeschwindigkeit verändern. Aber gemessen daran, wie starr die Traditionen sind und wie lange das da alles schon so ist, sind die Entwicklungen der letzten Jahre total krass. Also die sind eigentlich total auf der Überholspur. Wenn du dir anguckst, Frauen durften das erste Mal überhaupt wählen. Letztes Jahr. Vor vier Monaten. Vor vier Monaten durfte man in Saudi-Arabien das erste Mal wählen. Das musst du dir mal reinziehen, das ist schon krass. Jetzt kannst du natürlich argumentieren, wie viel Einfluss hatten die und so, aber das sind krasse Neuerungen. Das sind Reformen, in denen du eigentlich nicht mehr zurück kannst.
Keine 50 Jahre nachdem die Schweiz das auch hinbekommen hat.
Du hast diesen ökonomischen Druck, du hast diese junge Bevölkerung. Das Land wird sich weiter verändern und ich habe das Gefühl, dass auch alle Leute im Land das merken. Es stehen uns große Veränderungen bevor. Es ist unklar, welche das sind, aber du hast das Gefühl, wenn du im Land bist, hast du ein bisschen das Gefühl, es ist Elektrizität in der Luft. Es passiert irgendwas, bald. Die Leute haben zwar schon seit ein paar Jahren das Gefühl, dass bald was passiert, aber dieses Gefühl intensiviert sich. Allgemein ist es jetzt gerade so, wenn man sich anguckt, wie es aussieht mit Freiheit für Künstler, Künstlerinnen, Rechte für Frauen. Im Moment geht es eher wieder in die repressivere Richtung. Es werden gerade wieder mehr Leute, Blogger, Twitterer und so weiter verhaftet zu sehr absurden Haftstrafen verurteilt. Es wirkt alles sehr, als ob das Herrscherhaus sich sehr festklammert an einer alten Welt, die aber eigentlich dem Untergang geweiht ist sozusagen. Man könnte sagen, vielleicht wird es jetzt erst noch mal schlimmer, bevor es besser wird.
So das letzte Aufbäumen.
So könnte man das interpretieren, dass es ein letztes Aufbäumen ist, genau. Und dann ist aber unklar, wie diese Veränderung verstanden gehen wird, weil sie wird kommen, das Land muss sich verändern. Ich denke, am besten für das Land wäre, wenn es eine rasche, aber doch graduelle Veränderung wäre. Also wenn man versucht, das so zeitlich so ein bisschen zu entzehren und das irgendwie so ein bisschen gesteuert zu machen. So eine gesteuerte Demokratisierung, vielleicht sagt dann, erlaubt man den Frauen das Auto fahren, investiert viel weiter in die Bildung, erlaubt eine gewisse intellektuelle Öffnung des Landes, erlaubt mehr politische Partizipation, strickt vielleicht das Herrschaus in eine konzeptionelle Monarchie um. Meiner Meinung nach wäre das, was dem Land am besten tun würde. Weil wie gesagt, die meisten Menschen, die da leben, wollen gar keinen direkten Cut, sowas ganz anderem. Die wollen es vielleicht ein bisschen anders, aber mit dem prinzipiellen System sind viele Leute dort erstmal sehr zufrieden.
Das zeigt sich ja auch, dass man jetzt nicht einfach so ein Demokratie-Monster aufstülpen kann, ohne dass man auch die entsprechenden Traditionen zumindest über die Zeit ansatzweise entwickelt hat.
Genau, genau, man muss diese Tradition entwickeln. Die Leute müssen das ja auch erstmal lernen, das mit dem Wählen gehen und wie das funktioniert. Ich hab das jetzt gesehen, ich hab diese Wahlen beobachtet letztes Jahr und ich war überrascht davon, wie krass du einem Land beim Wählenlernen zugucken kannst. Also was uns total natürlich vorkommt, so ganz einfach. Es geht einfach um so Sachen wie, wo und wie kann man sich denn registrieren als Wähler. Und du hast das Gefühl, dass die diese Verfahren on the fly entwickeln oder zum Beispiel für die Partizipation der Frauen anpassen. Also da gibt es ganz, ganz viele Sachen, die zu lernen und die zu entwickeln sind und die irgendwie erst noch kommen und sich langsam verändern müssen. Ich glaube, es würde dem Land gar nicht mehr so gut tun, wenn es einen zu krassen Cut gibt. Aber gleichzeitig hast du halt diesen Druck, der aus vielen verschiedenen Richtungen gleichzeitig kommt. Du hast irgendwie den Druck durch den IS, durch islamische Terroristen, auch im eigenen Land. Es gibt immer wieder terroristische Anschläge in Saudi-Arabien. Kriegt man von außen auch nicht so mit, aber die haben viel Terrorismus im eigenen Land. Da werden ständig irgendwelche Moscheen, gibt Bombenanschläge und so weiter. Du hast die konservativen Eliten, die eigentlich wieder zurück in eine Zeit wollen, die es nicht mehr gibt. Du hast die jungen Leute, die wollen, dass sie auf YouTube und Twitter sagen können, was sie wollen und die mehr Partizipation wollen und so weiter. Und das trifft alles irgendwie so weiter auseinander. Dazu hast du den ökonomischen Druck. Die internationalen Konflikte. Es gibt auch ein Szenario, was ich jetzt auch nicht für vollkommen und plausible halte, dass das Herrscherhaus untergeht. In einem großen Bang. Und dann ist halt die Frage, was kommt danach? Und deswegen bin ich der Meinung, es wäre besser, wenn es langsam und geordnet diese Transition machen würde, als wenn es irgendwie zu krass ist. Weil man ja zum Beispiel auch am Ägypten sieht, dass es auch krass in die Hose gehen kann. Weil du hast einfach verschiedene Gesellschaftsgruppen, die unterschiedliche Dinge wollen und die in verschiedene Richtungen wollen. Und dass das alles ausgewogen repräsentiert wird in einem neuen Staat. Das muss sich halt erstmal irgendwie entwickeln. Das muss ausgehandelt werden. Und im Zweifelsfalle, wenn Machtvakuum entsteht, dadurch, dass die alten Herrscher-Eliten erstmal weg sind, dann gewinnt erstmal der Stärkere.
Jetzt haben wir gar nicht über Essen geredet. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das überhaupt ein Thema ist, aber ich hab mir gerade so überlegt, so zum Schluss, geht noch. Nee, aber ich hab mir gerade überlegt, so jetzt, wo du wieder da bist, was du denn am meisten vermissen wirst? Also ich meine, du hast natürlich die Berliner Busfahrer erstmal vermisst, deswegen bist du jetzt hier. Was vermisst man jetzt sozusagen in einem Land, in dem man eigentlich vor allem die Entbehrungen, also die kulturellen Entbehrungen, erstmal so primär wahrnimmt?
Es ist jetzt tatsächlich nicht irgendwie Essen oder so, weil Arabisch essen oder Shisha rauchen wird mir in Berlin auch geboten. Könnte ich. Ich kann auch hier irgendwie Falafel essen oder...
Aber ist es auch so gut hier?
Es ist nicht so original, aber it's good enough so. Okay, das Klinik ist wirklich absolut unkleinlich und hat eigentlich verhältnismäßig wenig mit dem Land an sich zu tun, aber mir fehlt wirklich krass einfach die Sonne, weil in Saudi-Arabien ist einfach immer Sommer, immer, always, all the time. Und du glaubst nicht, wie häufig ich hier jetzt in den letzten zwei Wochen in Berlin saß und so den Impuls hatte von, wäre eigentlich Zeit mal wieder an den Strand zu gehen. Wäre eigentlich cool, mal wieder eine Stunde in der Sonne zu liegen und einfach ein bisschen Sonne zu tanken. Und mir ist wirklich gerade auch so ein bisschen unklar, wie ich den kommenden Berliner Winter überstehen soll. Und den darauffolgenden und den darauffolgenden und den darauffolgenden. Also wenn man sich erst mal daran gewöhnt hat, im Ausland im Sommer zu leben und den deutschen Winter eigentlich nur aus dem Gemecker der Twitter-Freunde zu kennen, aber nicht mehr aus eigener Anschauung. Und die Leute so, und es ist immer so dunkel und so matschig und kalt und die Heizung im Büro ist kaputt und ich guck raus und draußen sind 38 Grad und es ist Winter. Und ich denke, ich glaube, ich gehe am Wochenende erstmal in den Pool. Das klingt wirklich absolut, aber daran gewöhnst du dich krass, dass du das immer zur Verfügung hast.
Ja, wobei ich fand's ein bisschen, ich fand's ein bisschen fett. Also, als ich in Dubai war, mir ist es...
Na schau mal, ich bin so ein Sommermensch. Also, ich geh zu, der Sommer in Saudi-Arabien, der ist wirklich krass. Weil da kannst du einfach nicht mehr draußen sein. Das geht einfach nicht mehr. Das Meer hat 32 Grad und du hast 48 Grad Tag zu Tag.
Furchtbar.
Das ist schon ein bisschen crazy, das gebe ich zu. Aber den Sommer übersteht man, der ist nicht so lang. Und der größte Teil des restlichen Jahres ist ein Sommer, den ich sehr, sehr gut ertragen kann. Jedenfalls sehr viel besser als den Berliner Winter. Das fehlt mir so ein bisschen. Und das andere, was mir so ein bisschen fehlt, ist so dieses, wie ich gesagt hab, so fremde Städte, die man sich zu eigen macht, die sich dann so ein bisschen wie ein gezähmtes Pferd anfühlen. So dieses, man kennt sich, das ist meine Hood. Da weiß ich, wo die Sachen sind. Da kenn ich meine Leute, da hab ich meine Rituale. Da fahr ich immer lang. Da macht man diese Dinge. Und jetzt mach ich halt andere Sachen. Jetzt bin ich in Berlin und es ist cool. Und hier kann ich ganz andere Sachen machen. Und ich hab mich auch extrem darauf gefreut, zurückzukommen nach Deutschland. Und die, meine Twitter-Follower wissen, dass ich immer Bilder von meinem kleinen, persönlichen Zurück nach Hause komm Kalender gepostet habe. Aber nur noch 19 Tage und nur noch 7 Tage.
Ich war schon ein bisschen verzweifelt.
Also ich hab mich wirklich auch extrem gefreut. Aber das Gras ist immer da grüner, wo man gerade nicht ist.
Ja, die Sonne, die ist immer so eine Sache. Aber ich hab meinen Frieden schon lange gemacht. Hier mit dem Wetter muss man auch.
Ja, mit dem Wetter aber dann auch. Genau, die Berliner Schnauze und das Gemecker so. Das irritiert einen doch einfach auch noch eine ganze Weile, dass die Leute nicht so herzlich sind und nicht so viele Floskel benutzen. Und man gewöhnt sich auch komische nonverbale Gesten zum Beispiel an oder Verhaltensmuster, die die Leute dann nicht verstehen, wenn man zurückkommt. Also zum Beispiel, ich hab aus Ägypten eine Angewohnheit mitgebracht. In Ägypten, wenn jemand dich was fragt und du verneinst das, dann schneidest du so kurz. Also das heißt dann einfach nee. Also statt das Wort nein zu sagen, schneidest du einfach so und sagst so. Wenn dich jemand fragt, fährst du um drei und dann sagst du nee. Oder willst du noch ein bisschen Wasser? Dann schneidest du so. Und als ich zurückkam, hatte ich eine Freundin, die sich total beschwert hat, dass ich diese Angewohnheit mitgebracht habe. Und meinte, das klingt total arrogant und herablassend. Und ich dachte so, hä, wieso, weil das machen doch alle. Und sie sagt, ja nicht hier in Deutschland. Oder eine Sache, die ich jetzt aus Saudi-Arabien mitgebracht habe, dass man sich so die Hand aufs Herz legt als Dankesgeste zum Beispiel. Also entweder für vielen Dank oder für nein danke. Und das sagt man halt, das macht man halt auch häufig anstelle irgendwas zu sagen. Und wenn mir im Restaurant jemand was gibt oder sonst irgendjemand was Nettes macht und ich leg die Hand auf mein Herz, dann merke ich, wie niemand das registriert als Dankesgeste. Weil die Leute das nicht kennen und nicht sehen. Also die hätten wahrscheinlich lieber vielen Dank gehört von mir.
Na hier rufen sie eher noch den Notarzt.
Wenn ich mir die Hand aufs Herz leg. Nee, aber das sind so Sachen, die du da mitbringst, wo du dich erstmal wieder einfinden musst.
Was reizt dich jetzt als nächstes aus der arabischen Welt?
Viele Sachen reizen mich.
So als Ort.
Als Ort, ja ich weiß. Viele Orte reizen mich. Ich kann mir... Okay, Top drei. Tunesien, Libanon und Platz drei. Vielleicht Jordanien oder eins an den anderen nordafrikanischen Ländern. Also gerne auch nochmal an den Golf. Golf starten finde ich auch spannend. Oman finde ich cool. Ich war letztes Jahr im Herbst im Oman. Aber so, genau, Libanon, Jordanien finde ich cool. Ich war letztes Jahr im Sommer in Beirut und fand das extrem cool. Ich hab mich jetzt auch auf einen Job in Beirut beworben. Beirut ist toll. Und die nordafrikanischen Länder sind ja auch gerade in so einem Transformationsprozess. Und gerade bei Tunesien hab ich das Gefühl, das wird die westliche Perspektive, dass man noch so hofft, Tunesien könnte noch die Kurve kriegen. Als Land in einem Transformationsprozess, das seinen Weg findet zu einer islamisch beeinflussten, islamisch geprägten Demokratie. Und das wäre schon cool und das ist spannend. Tunesien ist so ein Land, wo ich sagen würde, da habe ich jetzt so nach Saudi-Arabien, wäre das nächstes Land, wo ich sagen würde, diesen gesellschaftlichen Umbruchsprozess, den würde ich mir gerne live und vor Ort angucken, wenn irgendein Job um die Ecke kommt, der passen könnte. Der passen könnte, genau.
Bisher mit deinem Französisch und deinem Arabisch bestens vorbereitet.
Aber ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen, jetzt erstmal irgendwie ein Jahr oder zwei in Berlin zu bleiben und dann nochmal wieder ins Ausland zu gehen. Mal gucken, wie sich das so alles entwickelt. Aber ich kann mir das sehr gut vorstellen, nochmal ins Ausland zu gehen, da wo die Sonne scheint, da auch wieder für ein oder zwei Jahre zu arbeiten. Ich mein, endlos kann man das vielleicht auch nicht machen. Hängt ja dann auch so von. Ja, das spielt darauf an, dass ich erzählt habe, dass ich extrem viele Podcasts gehört habe im Ausland. Das liegt jetzt aber auch daran, dass ich in Saudi-Arabien wirklich auch alleine war und auch alleine gewohnt hab. Ich hab das erste Mal in meinem Leben tatsächlich in Saudi-Arabien alleine gewohnt. In einer Einzimmerwohnung, in einem Compound. Und da ist halt abends niemand, wenn man von Arbeit nach Hause kommt. Und deswegen bin ich wirklich die letzten anderthalb, zwei Jahre fast jeden Abend zu irgendwelchen Podcasts, die ich gehört hab, eingeschlafen oder hab die im Hintergrund laufen lassen, wenn ich in meiner Wohnung Geschirr gespült hab oder gebügelt hab oder Kartoffeln geschält hab oder irgendwie sowas. Aber ich hab ja auch eine Beziehung hier in Deutschland schon seit vielen Jahren. Und der Plan ist eher, wenn ich noch mal ins Ausland gehe, dann würde ich die, glaube ich, mitnehmen. Das heißt, ich würde vielleicht nicht ganz so viele Podcasts zum Einschlafen.
Ja, trotzdem könnten das, glaube ich, jetzt gerade eine ganze Menge Leute nachvollziehen, die das gerade gehört haben.
Das mit dem Podcast, ja. Ich bedanke mich auch ganz herzlich. Vielen Dank, dass ich so viel über so viele Dinge reden konnte, die mir am Herzen liegen und ich interessant finde.
Ja, genau. Wir finden das ja auch interessant. Und das war jetzt mal so ein Weltenabriss, den ich auch mal hier einbringen wollte. Und ich hoffe auch, euch hat es allen gefallen. Wir hören uns bald wieder. Das war es mit CRE.